yeah Chris Leah's got a car and he's got
terrible shoes and he's eating oatmeal
on the fly on some Jordan Air Force Ones
the original I know those are Air Force
Ones those little J's yeah it just
bothers me that you guys get it I hate
that Chris does this he goes did we
start yeah all right what you hate you
show me your shoes and you go there so
dope they oh yeah you're a grown man
you're 36 men I'm young you're 36 I'll
let you know when I'm in adult house
that yo-yo at heart I'll let you know
when I'm gonna thought those that look
I'm a kid bro I know I'm just a little
pup when do you think Oh cuz we were
talking so young we were talking before
we got here we're here yeah you're so
yeah it's like our friend Stevie Broncos
bro he just spent all day on Instagram
they went to the gym he's like 16 year
old girl
yeah he goes and Brian goes you know at
least he's young he's not bad yeah 30
and Stevie goes I am 32 not that young
bro I just pour myself into one thing
and before stand-up it was it was
jiu-jitsu dude I would do it for six
years and then before that it was
working out you know and I just didn't
give a [ __ ] about anything else it's
just one thing that I like doing and
then I just you took you know it was
zero and I want that's another thing I
want to talk about is we were talking
about this before we started recording
you used to be late all the time yeah
and now you're not yeah
because you just changed that I just
changed and that means that you're an
even bigger [ __ ] than I thought
yeah because no because he was just
being late and he could change it like
that well no means you were coming to
make a joke but I told hurt my feelings
man like I said if you're gonna be late
I don't want to do this yeah I thought
once I went off hurt my friend I know I
looked and I go I will never be late
again
oh interesting he has a mid late you
know what what one of the things that he
did once we were at dinner I think I
probably told this maybe on another
podcast but we were at dinner it was me
you Josh Lawson Will Sasso and Craig
culture I think in culture what I say
Chad Cole yeah chuckles and and someone
else yeah and Tom Cruise no it wasn't
Tom corrected I hang
those guys so I don't I always confuse
them okay so anyway yeah it wasn't them
okay so uh and and I had a set and and
and and Chad and and and Josh were like
yeah I I don't know I don't know if they
ever see me do stand-up so they're gonna
come to the Comedy Store you gonna come
so I say yeah so I got to go I want to
make sure I get on so meet me at the
Comedy Store so I left early and then
all you all you guys went to go to the
Comedy Store I get on so I was like just
so you know everyone's coming I was got
him seats I got onstage I get offstage
and I'm like where the [ __ ] is everybody
you guys weren't there and then and then
Josh or Chad I was talking and they were
like hey yeah or when you come in and I
was like when my comment on what I was
like you guys were supposed we made the
comments over the [ __ ] are you guys and
he says oh you uh Brian said you were
going up at the improv and I was like
what you said Brian said you were you
you rotate you changed it and he was
going to the high-profit hop I remember
that no no no was Brian doing standard
oh yes [ __ ] just one no I actually
think it was worse than that he just
wanted to be at the improv because he
liked the hang there better and everyone
was like he just lied to them and said
nag Christian to his set up at The
Improv let's go there it's like and I
called him like this [ __ ] and he
didn't say hello the first thing because
he knew like what he did was dead yeah
he picks up the phone he says you ruined
the night I went to call Chris I called
him and I get a text he doesn't pick up
the phone I get a text and all it says
is nah yep I was thing about this the
other day how special is the Comedy
Store compared to other places now like
just the heiau why I don't know when he
did before I don't know anything dude
sometimes it would be and now it's it's
the hottest place in Los Angeles says
it's like the 80s or the incredible yeah
there's a renaissance going on
dude I have everyone I mean no you're
not man it you know that's what they say
whoo-hoo when they say be know the
Comedy Store press release always like
this what these press release no but
there's the lion and then there's all
the rest of these stay like
pound-for-pound you
the lion of comedy you don't hear that
no yay you know any of that don't know
you're not gonna make my I've heard a
little chat you know what you're not
fathered a little about this Comedy
Store press release dude I'll tell you
they are saying they are saying though
they are like and I fir they're like
dude they're like a dick no I'm not I'm
not trying to be a dick I swear to God
what is this legit [ __ ] okay
apparently when I go to the Comedy Store
people are it's very [ __ ] weird I
didn't get it for a long time but
they're handing me like footballs and
[ __ ] what is that why why I don't I
don't play sports or [ __ ] like that
weeks would go by and they'd be like
they want you to sign them I was like yo
me signs they were like you go champ and
I was like okay I don't want this [ __ ] I
don't get it I thought it was a joke
that somebody said on a pirate or
whatever dude they're calling me the
quarterback of the comedy am I getting
all these footballs its mouth women
we're like now so I'll say that because
they're calling me Simba no wow is it
your new logo is an eagle right yeah cuz
you're like an eagle yeah not a sonic
this is [ __ ] I forgot to say this I
was that I was in this meeting I forget
who it might have you would know I was
in this big meeting I was wearing your
sweatshirt and it's like the ovo yeah
yeah yes I don't know it's like the ovo
Drake yeah but it's not that out Chris
is Eagle and one guy is it a parent yeah
no it's a [ __ ] eagle it's an eagle
bro it's a round I'm saying parrots
plump look look it's not plump but it
looks like the ovo and the guy you can
tell was like trying to be hip and cool
the powerful Diaz oh my son has that
Drake section I go no that would be cool
and then the guy goes I think I him go I
think I'm like and I heard I'm like no
it's actually my boys he's obviously
just wrong yeah [ __ ] copy yeah yeah
it's something jobs mocking narrates
thing yeah and that's how it started
area have an eagle on his shirt or an
owl
an owl so you girls are more gangster
than owl so you kind of one-up Drake huh
I mean I don't looking like that but
chin bring up the braces sweatshirt
Eagle sweatshirt I want to just I want
to look at this because I think you need
work on the bird I feel like it's
apparent well you're [ __ ] wrong spell
my name right but I know I know I know I
know I know listen I don't worry about
that how has it been going Chris the
whole hood it's down there the black one
yeah dude let me explain something Oh
see the back go back
that's not even me go down the middle
hey don't talk about just by the promise
that looks a lot like a macaw it
literally does look like a parrot you
think no here's why your son saying that
parent here's why you're saying that
it's not why is it's it's still which is
the point and it's not like this joke
that's the [ __ ] joke you pieces bro
obviously it's not a big deal legal
dressed as a parent is that fair no it's
not fair but it literally looks nothing
like a parent and that's final
notify yeah legal that's what happens to
the Eagles have much bigger beaks buddy
they're a lot bigger they got they're
bigger and they grow you're actually
I've seen a bald eagle sir you're
actually wrong that you bring a bald
eagle first chin also what the [ __ ] who
are those people I'm taking pictures
with those be your fans third parent but
what okay that's got hat flowers on a
little bit look at your leg I'm not mad
that shows your dick though you can see
your dick pulled yeah I got a you got a
dick in that pic Kristen's got a dick
I've seen yeah Chris show oh no we've
seen the dick when he's doing the yeah
Chris Chris it's I pulled his dick out
when it was kind of hard
we're doing a podcast and he goes there
you go and I go what the [ __ ] I don't
even know that well you just sit here
you go you can show a guy your dick when
it's soft but if you show you guys that
I'm chubby
now now we got to be pretty good friends
at yes point no that's how it goes
swear you get comforted and he goes suck
no you know it's Chris said okay look
just exactly like that [ __ ] look at
that one of the Browns and Chris look at
not
and you're gonna have longer logos heads
to round now presents a mom draught
yourself Oh Chris because and you have a
stub beak on that that's a parrot stubby
cannot your Eagle has a long beak Ryan
is literally exactly what it is hey I
love the shirt man that's a no it's not
look at it want to look up a parrot now
look up a parrot bring up a [ __ ]
parrot chin this is parrot mahkumat Oh
Eric hey you're being mean that's a
[ __ ] parrot I'm talking about that is
your shirt dude no it's not the second
one in the second line down that green
one you parrot it's not a parrot's beak
goes down that's an eagle and everyone
[ __ ] knows it no I don't know if they
do it looks first of all it's a small
Hawk it's a if anything I'll give you
into tiny Jose small hawk I want all
those birdies your company car you're
beautiful there yeah is your company
called some all hawk Ryan you know that
what you're saying shut up at the right
time of the best my buddy steady I'd be
talking and getting excited to go what
shut up you right away shuts down every
shut up it might be the rudest thing you
can ever say - yeah
hey January and February pilot season
yeah hold on you don't text while you're
doing our podcast yeah I do dude I was
texting to get me out of here call me
with an emergency I sent it to so many
people look at your shitty posture see
this place man whole trainer wouldn't
appreciate it out sit like this - like
hey did you try that hey Chris did you
try to have you on a diet - yeah dude I
ate so many [ __ ] ice creams last
night why wanted a why wanted to look at
ice cream just do whatever you want yeah
you can actually [ __ ] cookies and ice
cream sandwiches bro mononym water
them went to sleep after that BAM and
you look you still want the [ __ ] man
dude hey man I don't give a [ __ ]
oh you whatever the [ __ ] I want this
room dude I got [ __ ] ice cream
sandwiches I [ __ ] was naked on my
couch okay look did you watch it old
stuff on my carpet god damn it did you
watch these sports nope why not
didn't want to okay we don't have
watched no disrespectful is this I
watched 35 minutes of an episode of Luke
Cage and then I turned it off that's so
disrespectful
it wasn't even from the beginning to 35
I started it in the middle and and got
almost to the end any part of any show I
want and turn off whenever I want you
have no respect there's no respect I ate
some of the ice cream sandwiches and I
had other ones I could have put in the
freezer I left them out why I don't give
a [ __ ] make the place made them the post
based guy picked them up brought him to
me I ate some of them they're still on
my [ __ ] coffee table I don't give a
[ __ ] Grizz there's some Lacroix on the
carpet you have respectful no I don't
you do I don't why not me okay the first
thing I want to say no no the first
thing I want to say is okay what pick a
shade man pick a shade with that like a
shitty Crayola node why are you dressed
like Chris Gaines ten you know when
Garth Brooks where's the tiger and color
church it'll be green here on one side
and the black on one side you do
anything I don't mean to open up the
[ __ ] I don't mean to open up the show
with a huge move like that but no people
I made I knocking swear just get that
because it's you look like an actor from
American Pie dude holder's dude it looks
you got that for free
that's such as that's such a [ __ ] I
did get it for free look man dude that's
such a hoodie you'd wear for free would
not buy that you never got that [ __ ]
shades off right now this is no I gotta
wear these dude
futures to Bry CEO there was all that
otherwise I wouldn't have them on but
future no right did you see what I did
is bright you see the picture I tweeted
the Instagram yeah about the black and
white photo the one I'm you said yeah
that he yeah Oh bro oh you know what's
weird is that is that you you posted it
only hours after he posted it not days
after he posted well I that's why
there's a new episode of fighter in the
kid right when it comes out hey there's
a new episode of fighter in the kid
sixty days ago and there's already a new
episode yeah cuz I like to create a lag
don't do that hey Chris that is the more
II can I ask Chris the serious question
yeah yeah hey Chris so do you think
Brian fondled Chuck Liddell's balls last
time the groom oh he just Powerball dude
when we live up dude
we were hanging out having a good time a
silly [ __ ] loosey goose time yeah
Chuck Liddell walks in this guy is a
transformer and transformed into a
[ __ ] dick diver yeah no oh everyone
turns into a fighter jet but me I turn
into a [ __ ] no no no listen hold on like
talking about training and sparring do
you know as soon as you like then you go
bro oh my god you don't look a day over
25
oh don't run goes like this Eva honey
look yeah he looks good but huh
he looks good but except for huh what
are you doing dude you can do what you
want it's free conch don't promote your
shirt it's free card no there's not
congratulations we're here you're
welcome because I have a podcast now
subscribe to my podcast congratulations
and I want you to unsubscribe now
anything Brian
I'm killari I want you I like my podcast
is not I'm not saying anything
okay well it's true no Chris the future
is bright but my girls are [ __ ] take
them off Nega to see inside
hey you don't there's not a lot of depth
bro come on
what are you tired you if I drew a
[ __ ] picture of your brain coffee
hanging out and with my sidekicks and
chicks and chicks man lazy dude all that
lazy day all I think your book if we're
all books Eric Chris is a comic yeah is
that fair well dude con you look so
graphic novel yeah okay dude I mean The
Watchmen okay my little Watchmen No am I
your hero what do you think seriously
what do you think you would be the sloth
no do you know what I I have a
superpower what I can open up doors
without even touching now at the grocery
shirt
Oh Brian didn't get the job how do you
do that he says I do it cuz my fans open
the doors for me dude your fans don't
travel with you around that you've seen
that ah you know what my fans are there
they and I'm not trying to be a dick to
you and bud no no listen every time you
say that it's dead no no but let me just
explain what my fans are and it's no big
deal and I don't give a [ __ ] and I don't
even want I didn't want to say this out
loud because I don't care but I'll say
it just for argument's sake let's have a
conversation
so my fans our fans what we would call
fans and life right now hold on it's
just that there's there's cuz I'm always
evolving and always like challenging
argument this guy teaches me teaches
yeah and then you your fans are as we
know and again who cares who cares what
your fans are some are not yet in high
school and others are in high school
and it's not incredibly fickle so crazy
also refer themselves as babies they
call me hell you don't our fan bases
what tea fat cake oh [ __ ] hey hey hey
Chris but a chin disappeared when he
went like that here on yeah I can't wow
you're just no cheer Oh bro bro you
human bird we are uh we are [ __ ]
twenty we are thirty we are 40 or 50 my
god your babies dude what [ __ ]
why are you babies because dude [ __ ]
this alpha secretly beta [ __ ] bro I got
it all figured out man calm down I'll do
what I want and it'll be fine and
because you're a buddy everyone's fun oh
we're gonna do [ __ ] you know what I
mean no you're not saying anything you
know about this man say about this man
what number one guest on fighter in the
kid oh dude any people say forget though
okay Will Sasso Michael Rapaport yeah
make way for [ __ ] freak punch that's
hey you showed me your body yesterday
pretty damn good right no I don't think
so what okay did you see the cocky
region I didn't you all I saw his dick
in the bathroom I leaned over and saw it
no but you got to see you when I Stan
honey no it's not he swung it around
like a road around tassel no I don't
wash my hands after I piss you I don't
either who does they're weird it's my
dick I was poor I touch my exactly and I
don't touch the door I do elbow it yeah
it is impressive because the legend of
Chris D'Elia let's be honest the legend
started on the find the kid no because
Ari Shaffir is mention you dick about
the Comedy Store listen to me and Brian
chimed in about your day I'm Brian got
all the shut out it no it's fine no it's
fine you heard about it
the masses yeah but but what what what
sucks is um don't look at your fit when
I get why I got a Fitbit when I get when
I when I when I get a boner I faint a
lot because of the bad blood lose a lot
of blood
oh yeah I just go oh you are okay is
that a sundial they go like hey no you
ate sushi why were you there by yourself
dude I [ __ ] you know what I do what
not only do I do I not invite anyone I
send a text out and I say I'm getting
sushi no one's invited and then I go by
myself [ __ ] you know why dude because I
[ __ ] up here bro hey I got a [ __ ]
blast can you do that vide have a blast
I have a blast dude I just think
anything I want nobody's there to
[ __ ] be like ah but also [ __ ] them
dude I just chill you're right hang out
I have a good time and I eat sushi and I
go like this and I think about stuff
what do you talk about last to do what
do you think about like seriously um I
think about like the people around me
and if someone falls and that would be
funny or like I'll think about something
I could talk about on stage or I think
about my mom or I worry about you don't
worry really why would I worry why would
I worry you don't worry dude no you
don't wake up with like anxiety
sometimes yeah sometimes I do I felt
what I don't know and then I and then I
go like this what am i anxious about and
I go at this do you ever get anxious
that it's gonna end by some weird thing
as in like an accident or I think about
weird [ __ ] yeah I guess so sure
the dragons are you you you know you how
worried you what yeah you worry you're
like me you uh no I'm not like you
no no no you were yeah you get like a
speck you think you have stage 5 cancer
why don't we like that that's why I
worry more about like like how long will
I keep still like how many how long
they'll keep coming up with material
like you might gonna like next month I'm
like yes and then the roads over that
happens all the time when especially
after you shoot a special then you go I
got to start all over again
yeah am I gonna and how am I gonna do
cuz you know I don't remember coming up
with
[ __ ] I know no beavers dilip it decided
me interrupt you ever do a bit and then
he like well how the [ __ ] did I come up
yes
did someone help me with that's what I
mean where did I get up from right and
how am I to call a new [ __ ] exactly like
that's what I mean at that do you feel
away yeah well my last one of my last
tour I was doing that act for like a
year and a half two years and then
afterwards I was like what the [ __ ] do I
do and then I just started but I just
that's why I constantly book shows and
go on stage because I'm like oh I'll
keep I'm not gonna do the old [ __ ] yeah
and then I'll just do that I'll do new
[ __ ] yeah you know even if it's not good
and then it really soon it kind of like
takes a life yeah yeah exactly
it warms on its own yeah mmhmm yes that
is interesting like you just kind of
have to trust that it's gonna happen and
Ana and it's true you just keep doing it
until something you have any idea give
Netflix done let you know how your
semester did man I'm fine I just know
from like tweets and hilarious they can
get kind of gauge right from I mean well
you because you're your Twitter's and
social medias gonna be more your fans
you know I'm saying the bottom so you're
like oh it's great but yeah be getting
new ones and people say oh I don't know
who you were or um or or you can tell
because of your crowds get bigger you
know that makes sense yeah for sure
that's the big thing because specials
everything these days right well yeah I
mean yeah yeah and as you look at it cuz
like I watched Seinfeld's new special if
you watch it I didn't say nothing
brilliant and it's it's all material
yeah yeah I heard prove that sounds like
a documentary to know it's like stand-up
but and just go it shows like a quick
clip of his childhood and then goes back
I guess it shows like old stuff but it's
also old Mattia just to show that it
stood up over time and still you know
they say but but I watched that and then
in the queue it goes Dave Chappelle bill
burr Chris D'Elia
that's where Netflix is just done all
right yeah oh you watch Chris Rock check
out Chris D'Elia and when you get in
that cuz how how big is flippable
Dave ship yeah yeah yeah yeah oh that's
hilarious
God he's similar that and they watch
that I also think I [ __ ] up my the
special I didn't I don't know [ __ ] up
the right word but when I this one this
new one that came out man on fire which
is on Netflix I just said that alright
man I know you watch it yeah but don't
so nobody know I
I didn't actually even notice I was
looking at the camera oh you but okay
it's a lot flicks yeah thank you very
much all right stream it doesn't matter
but and so you [ __ ] up on that one no
I'm the incorrigible which is the one
that was my second one which is right
before man on fire on Netflix you can I
think I started slow like I put all the
good [ __ ] at the end yeah you know oh
and people have the attention yeah they
don't know
I'll watch comments on there yeah it's
like yeah I'll be 20 min don't like this
is yeah they don't so I so I open man on
fire with you this stuff that I thought
was the the hardest-hitting [ __ ] that's
that's smart but that's also why Netflix
it's just people's attention span yeah
but that's why they're leaning they're
doing a lot more 30 minutes yeah not not
even to mention my incorrigible was like
an hour and 20 minutes over over yeah
about an hour too long for me yeah but
really and the man on fire is 64 minutes
or something like that no that's not
what they're doing okay no I know you
know what actually they are doing that
because that's the Dead Rising they're
ghosts because they want to see it to
special' do you sign a multi like term
deal or we don't sign a multi we sign
maybe you could send a multi multi you
said multi so I don't think hey Brobee
State John that's so not that's so
[ __ ] good with that one word yeah he
never got he'll know it's certain words
oh he's working it I'll speak for a
living I don't I don't I didn't but I
guess you could but I don't think they
do that though dude there I don't think
they never I never was never an option
for me
so it's just one it so if it doesn't do
well just one and done they're like all
right well you know I'm saying I'd yeah
if it doesn't do well it's kind of a
weird format because you do one gasps
yeah and they can just do your next one
with whoever granted there though yeah
biggest show in town you just guy I'm
gonna go over here now yeah I mean I
don't know I mean I'm [ __ ] no I you
do you know I have to on there so it's
good to have I think it's good to have
to on there and so guys have
or five on there I guess all efflux what
doesn't burn Phil where are probably mmm
Logan has what three two on there
mmm so I don't know but uh I don't know
if Iowa like before Netflix became what
he came I always thought it was I was
like I'll be cool to do one like I did
one for Comedy Central did and then the
next one I did for Netflix sounds like I
wonder where I'll do the next one but
then Netflix got so big that I was like
ah you just gotta be on you have to yeah
to compete and like I don't know if like
although you know if hula would do one
but they don't do him I would be willing
to bet they'd start to get into it I
heard they were going to but that was
like a year and a half yesterday would
cuz they just won all those Emmys
they beat Netflix like destroyed they
want to do it means then any network
through and it's Hulu so I would assume
and then Amazon Facebook's do what I'm
what I'm fourteen I know a lot of times
you so much to do it you know what do
you know and I feel like you you you
would know this to I feel like Chris is
starting to get more and more into act
and I feel like it back then takes up
you done with time exam surprised you're
not doing more acting do you actually
feel that way I love stand up no yeah
because you're not you are very doctor
thank you you know I'll just slip in and
out of characters and it's like he ever
hit team and people don't even realize
any sort of them cockney thing that's
all you know came to me you know I mean
no he's just jumped into a cab it's
lawyer it's plush like you know when you
go into you know when you're lying in
out like near a pool and then all of a
sudden you're like I'm gonna get in
there
sploosh that's what it is character
right you know I'm not bad at all
and you're from the east of London or
all over
army brat really oh you did a movie ops
again you can't see what the movie is
well no it was called life in a year I
don't know if I'm allowed to say what
what I played though really yeah we
almost want to see it
how are you proud of it do you think I
think so I have no idea cry like do it
okay do it okay you know what I mean you
have to go overboard thank you you have
to overboard on crying most people think
subtlety is only apologize I'm drug lord
and apologize
I don't everybody you know I mean like
that yeah yeah yeah [ __ ] dude
right right cuz I was gonna kill you I
know and then I I felt pity yeah dude
because I would take acting classes I
mean laughs you grew up in the business
he took a shame to voices voice and
dance I didn't take dance I know it was
a [ __ ] well tell but you took you
took voice does this answer your
question remember when you and I tried
to sing serious yeah yeah yeah Brian
does that Brian likes to relive the
glory days that's all he has he doesn't
have a bright future that's not true
you've got a checkered past well that's
[ __ ] true in a bad way I've got kids
I don't know about and if I find out
I'll ignore the many ways yeah cuz I'm
selfish [ __ ] it's selfish hey and
selfish who are we talking to
we're brined it oh we have my party with
rolling over time about that time when
you really thought you could sing like
Brian was he did like what deaf there
the Comedy Jam thing you know where's
comedian see oh yeah goddamn comedy I'm
if I wanted to I could be this thing
dude all right
oh I mean obviously I could but a little
bit like yours a little bit you I know
how hard it is when you hear like skylar
astin you're like i know forget it yeah
he's like Broadway and he can actually
sing but yeah like there's some guys
we're hearing like Brian's not bad you
know like you like it was like a 80s
rock you're singing mother there's one
note to it I guess I mean I'm still not
doing it but it you can kind of get mama
you know what I mean I just killed a man
yeah I know I know you like Freddie mine
now it's stupid but but but I can talk
about a town oh my god ever yeah no but
um wait wasn't gonna say [ __ ] that thing
no I don't know but uh oh yeah I know I
hate when I talk about this on my
podcast congratulations subscribe
unsubscribe them and subscribe to mine
and ever and so but they well I'm my mom
thinks I can sing and it bothers me so
much when she legit things yeah she's
like you could have been a singer and it
bothers me so much cuz it's so it's like
when somebody comes up to you and says
oh dude people say I should you stand up
and it's like turn round bye-bye but
parent bands are a little different like
I get this all the time my mom was just
out there she goes I don't understand
why you just don't audition for the new
Batman right right right right right
well that's yeah parents I know I know I
know man yeah people come up why don't
you do SNL you don't know how it works
oh that's a good idea yeah oh yeah I
never thought of that yeah yeah you are
somebody that could do that yeah you
have you thought about this until hey
bro I don't know that you would be happy
doing that or MJ Danna because you'd
have to give up a lot of stuff so it
becomes a problem like you know I'm
saying so you can do so if you do two
one-hour drama okay great
you better love it because you're their
fault you know let me tell you something
I've always said this too like for my
nightmare mmm is to be like the sixth
lead I'll CSI Shh oh my god why would
you ever take that but does people do
way ahead yeah I think we got something
oh my god you [ __ ] right in your
trailer just like this that my turn and
you can't hug this 19 times I'm pulling
it up right now
you're so [ __ ] right
oh dude you know who always gets that
part the funky chick with the hair like
yes
holster guys yeah or a guy that belongs
in a Verizon commercial yes can you hear
me now
that's what that is Hey Dude take a
knife out dude I'm telling you I did
I've done every CSI to hang myself done
every CSI right so really yeah I mean I
guess star and and in law and order and
just I remember sitting there wall nor
do I've done all I've done I've done an
episode of something yeah were you ever
on The Honeymooners
were you a mash no no oh no oh although
mash would have been fun I just want to
say I interrupted you we just started a
show we have the great Bobby Lee from
Saturday Night Live and oh where is it
nope right the same piece of [ __ ] you
were on hey oh yeah sorry a long time
man don't get bad on MADtv guys he's
well people can see it with the YouTube
video you're literally sitting like
we're about to do an intervention on you
you're holding on to the couch sort of
your hair is way too long I'm small
you're a subversive I think it's all I
can follow much and you're your bundle
up well I'm jealous I did the hair
jealous so I have to put like my hair
thank you so much you're very funny what
excuse me here your happy birthday by
the way thank you you're 45 and I'm from
45 weird way till you turn 50 I looked
in the mirror today and I went not make
it this is how you feel technically well
I'll tell you what 50 does and maybe
even 45 is it I looked in the mirror and
technically I've been on the planet for
50 years as of 15 minutes ago
and and my father just told me that and
I thought to myself if I die they go
50-year old man dies and people go yeah
let the good life that was a good day
it's a good stretch and even a long time
maybe evens bonus right and even I cuz
you know I'll be sitting to the right or
the left of Jesus yeah and when I'm
sitting right probably yeah well when
God makes Jesus move out of the way
and [ __ ] brushes the seat off and
lets me sit while the angels are singing
well he's a jolly good fellow for he's a
jolly good fellow cuz you know they're
gonna dance not happening sir dude you
don't know and yeah all my sins yeah I
have this joke where I have this this
feeling like if I died right now God
would have my entire life on one piece
of paper I'm like yeah like like with
this
look on his face that my dad had when he
get my report card you know how to mean
like you [ __ ] [ __ ] be--it'll ordered
be like you as 50 years old trying to
get into the hottest nightclub him just
being like mm-hmm I know right right but
if you were to go you would still be
really scared and depressed you don't
you don't feel like you lived a long
time like I'm 45 people oh that's a long
time ago no like if I die right now
they'll be such a bomb it'd be a bummer
well my agent with agents - it's like
you can't tell at all well that's crazy
and can I just say that right I know
I've never seen a mutant agent before to
my right well he's a giant III never
knew that they groomed that big soon he
was born in a lab he a young man
together yes right and June is a giant
man and I always thought that like Oh
two of five four but I'm average height
for Asian yeah no no we got we got the
Shrek of Koreans over here oh hey see
you guys should talk uncle Mario oh [ __ ]
oh come on uh go to taco man you speak
man as soon as I saw Bobby Lee at the
Comedy Store I went hey our producers
Korean and yo yeah you just say goes I
don't get fooled I went he yes hon III
could I'm going to buy you on the on the
on the open market
what yeah I'm gonna give a [ __ ] cuz
guess who's gonna be my kid but don't
get all emotion or do cry cuz I love
[ __ ] Korean boy tears on my dong
how's that sound
uh your [ __ ] but don't put me in that
little chest thing gonna go because I
don't want you to how long gonna be I'm
gonna be in there whatever whatever you
know I mean good your Atma win yeah I
don't suck dick or nothing of course you
do every resected did did not do I mean
real he's been real open up for me man
how do you define suck in event no like
a penis in your mouth I mean there is
that time
did you went to a phase where I was gay
no I never have never had a dick have
you Bobby yeah you know already
no I don't yeah yes you have yeah I love
how honest you are my guests and I know
you're not and what happened when we
what set the set the whole scenario well
when I was when I was in high school
came when I was nine I got molested by a
guy with Down syndrome don't laugh I'm
not laughing
why'd you laugh I'm it's just that it's
such a curveball I know can I just say
something I'm gonna say it again
and if you smile I'm gonna leave okay if
you smile his name alright but his name
yeah what's your new beginning chin all
right give me a second don't ya give me
a second all right
I just wasn't ready for that line I
understand I'm gonna say it again and if
and if you smile I'm gonna leave okay
all right hold on we can't write notes
smile right just hold on
no cuz then you're gonna laugh don't
laugh don't laugh get serious B's open
up here when I was you ready don't cover
your mouth of you though you can't cover
your mouth the thing is that I you know
I'm telling you something that's like us
it's vulnerable time expressing truth to
you I do yeah I get serious if you cover
your mouth I just feel like you're
laughing no let's do it alright so when
I was 9 I was brutally molested by okay
you can't say why because that's a
curveball good dog sister Hey look at
your mouth does that it's not a curse
don't say fruit ELISA had some all right
dawn I had your tips there so when I was
9 years old every day for summer
you can't throw [ __ ] in there y-yeah
alright let's try it again
don't do that how about this how about
I'm not gonna add more information the
information that I have on the table
okay expect that and I'm not gonna add
more all right okay so when I was nine
years old every day for summer I was
brutally molested by a guy with Down
syndrome I'm gonna let it slide that was
pretty good oh that was really good yeah
that was really good and I'll tell you
why every day is because he okay so I
lived in Minnesota people don't know and
you did yeah
for eight years that's landed a long
giant yeah I know I used to fitted I
know Minnesota I lived and there was a
you know during the summers there was
like a feel but in the winter it's like
that ice-skating rink and there's a
Shack in this field so there's a Zamboni
you know what a Zamboni is right it
cleans the ice yeah right hockey so
during the summer there was like a
pretty big Shack and there was a guy
with Down syndrome that was that lived
in it was a man a grown man I was a man
okay and he had candy on these rafters
and he was lure kids in with the candy
Wow
and he wouldn't like you couldn't that
suck as a different like that but he was
like he would show his penis right and
then like squeeze your ass it was like
weird you know but like I didn't give a
[ __ ] about I just wanted the candy kind
of can retarget
like the one the dipping ones dippin dot
all of those right yeah so every day and
this is like this is connected to my
addiction I'm willing to do anything to
get what I want that's interesting right
so even as a kid it's like I want the
candy all right if this guy's gonna ever
this if this guy's dick it's bad for me
because a guy with Down syndrome penis
is different
was it yeah did it look down I don't
really remember but it was it was just
like it did I don't know man is that why
they call them down sit good ideas who
want you to look at my file yeah
don't play innocent nobly innocent I was
a plan words for real curious I don't
want a soul there are people who have
children who are down there let's not
let's not you don't know we're not
making fun no we're not we're not making
fun yeah attention like that but I'm not
a doctor it's not a doctor or a
scientist but no it doesn't go down so
you did that for the dippin dots right
goddamn you not giving dogs how did you
you threw in dipping the tip stick we're
all throwing things in here yeah yeah
and so he was like if you want that suck
this he insane yeah talk like that but
don't paraphrase it yeah well that's
what happened in the nutshell right so
then check this out so then that
happened and then when I was 12 I
started my parents had my dad is
alcoholic and you guys to have this
refrigerator in the garage and my
mommy's just stocked with liquor and so
I suggest every night we'd go into the
garage and just get 12 even before
school that's out more often started
right and then really yeah so then when
I was 17 this actually happened I was at
a I would at a Recovery Center called
Ocean View Recovery Center it was in
Oceanside California and they have this
thing called knees to knees so it's
basically what you do is you sit in
front of your parent and you touch knees
on two chairs but then all the other
kids is family they're around in a
circle around you it's so embarrassing
I'm already embarrassed right my brother
was there I was 14 at a time my mom was
there and my dad your brother can't wait
to make fun of you what no he does so
check this out so uh I'm used to these
with my dad and I go yeah when I was
nine I was molested by a guy with Down
syndrome and then you can hear his pawns
in the room and this is what my dad did
he [ __ ] laughed and then I made my
brother laugh like my brother's like
tears coming down my brother and
my mom's not laughing and then I start
laughing and they think that we're
[ __ ] just crazy yeah but sometimes you
brought your dad probably didn't know
what to do
he's out of him what he did what you did
earlier yeah well it's right it's such a
curveball yeah it's such a mindfuck yeah
yeah yeah you don't know what to do but
laughs yeah yeah it does it's kind of
like but it's only with the dicks that's
not the dick though oh that wasn't that
wasn't a dick no oh you did psyche tear
down some guy's dick on the Zamboni
maybe maybe not I don't know okay but
then after that after that I'm not gonna
name names cuz I still talk to some of
these guys but you're worried about
telling the story now no I wouldn't do
it I'm happy to say their names I'm not
gonna say their names I mean I just had
a good know I had a dude that you a kid
that was like popular and then like he
would come in soon when I was drinking
like at 12 he would spend a night and
then he would go suck my dick and grab
my head and make me such day really yeah
I'm like five or six times how old are
you 12
huh and you just do it well I mean I
don't know if how good I mean I was just
like it was a kind of like I don't know
how to do I never it's not porn at the
time right so I guess it's just like I
made this face you know mean yeah yeah
and I didn't you know how you're
supposed to wrap your lips around the
penis I don't know I know you don't
well no I know you don't but I'm just
saying you've seen porn before right so
you've seen women give guys [ __ ] yes
I didn't do that
I think I just left the guy gigantic gap
yeah so he felt nothing
oh but it was still in my mouth I think
right that counts five or six times huh
so you guys would grab an old cold
brewski then he'd grab your hair and
make you sell his dick yeah mm-hmm okay
you're gay dude please explain this
conspiracy theory it's not a conspiracy
theory it's well known what happened
so he's we gotta loosen the delete honey
Bruce Lee died like an overdose aspirin
right to do now there was a there was a
squabble between the producer Simon chow
and he killed Bruce Lee and then years a
years later he killed Brandon Brandon do
you think that's complete
[ __ ] I don't like the wait you said
that okay
it's not [ __ ] [ __ ] okay I think
so because it's I saw a whole
documentary on Bruce Lee let me ask you
something right now
damn let me ask you say this Brendan
said and he laid down skating and they
start polyps
what I know you know what you knew we
said to me out there what I got Brendan
Shan what's his name
sob sob trying to shop shop dude Baba
yeah sha Shan because I go brilliant I'm
filling in for DeSean here and then he
goes oh I'm leaving do you not say that
oh because you have a crush on I love
him yeah I'm in love with him he's Iike
who is it yeah he's a purchase and did
he not be here because I was gonna be
here no he's in Syracuse doing stand-up
is this your Q's doing my job you know
what they call him we call it you know
what we call Brendan hungry eyes because
people who look at him have hungry eyes
you know what ching chong said to me
when i came here so sorry but ching
chong goes you know my remember to
change at all ting ting tong ting tong
said that I misused
I felt really weird about it why because
it was a kind of creepy in a creepy way
you know me like we have some sort of
like bond because are you both the same
Asian yes we are you're Korean how dare
you Bobby he's acting like he knows you
do you guys know each other yeah well
then how come you do know mr. chan mian
mian and they're coming come to me down
there you don't speak male what we don't
know - no mojo man we've done a circuit
that don't come up let them speak yeah
yeah well I'd be mastering so much that
nothing really comes out Iran does up
with know a rising drop or something
your dick goes yeah yeah and I was
making love to kalila day or night and
you know you say that at sexy times and
I was you know I'm about to I always
announce it yeah
I'm about the car I make the girl
announces yeah I'd say tell me when
you're coming out to come cuz that makes
me it's gonna come right with them I
have that you truck driving yeah welcome
so I roll over thank you so I roll over
and you know how you should start
drinking are to come right all right I
[Laughter]
don't I just lock both hands I my man I
go I go yeah this all belongs to you
or I just say for now grab your last
chance but in French fizzy test you oh
sorry that's just personal [ __ ] yeah I
do that you just got it use give you a
flashlight into my dark bedroom
go on over now after you did that you
just sound so sad you jerk off I jerked
off and I go uh I made the noise you
know ah right and literally nothing came
out yeah and she was watching me the
whole time yeah and then I heard I got
sorry it just got a whole lot more
talented in here we had the one and only
last year's guest of the year to come
back to back let's just declare me 2017
guest of the year dude it's gonna be
tough to meet Bobby Lee let me what you
brought the heat I'll be alright
I'm pretty confident I'm pretty
confident and also it's the fighter and
the kid but it we're back to being
Rappaport and the fighter because Bryan
Callen the 50 year old Bryan Callen
couldn't make it run a little bit well
Bryan Travolta and we say that you're
vaulting serious [ __ ] air is he late
and and let's remind that the folks you
tell me if I'm wrong with your Bobby
Lee's and your other guys your buck
guilty what's the highest rated fighter
in the kid episode ever
I'd have to look for probably one with
you on it no no no no no when I guest
hosting oh yes that was a big one yes no
not that a big warning let's say you you
wouldn't know cuz that was like last
year's last year yeah but but ever that
was the biggest either the kid episode
ever of 2016 well mm you had to gone up
oh yeah okay so I'm
as safe to say that the episode that
bryan callen wasn't there it did did
what he did well yeah witching which
makes you think like this like a [ __ ]
dead weight I win this [ __ ] boy the 54
when the fifty a coffee guild [ __ ] boys
yeah man [ __ ] [ __ ] man on the other side
of his life who shows up late for guests
see that means that getting taken for
granted the other thing is we had to
switch it right like to 9:30 big [ __ ]
do you know I'm saying I'm saying that
we did that for you because I know you
got a busy day shooting and then he's
saying all I'm something with the
Goldbergs Callen you're so full of [ __ ]
who you don't [ __ ] up showing up late
today hey it's okay we're take I'm good
it's higher that's just a [ __ ] fact
the ratings for the other so they're
gonna be high and then when he comes no
we put him in the [ __ ] guessing you
know my house like a little guest yeah
might have to we put him like like like
he's like the guy over there like we
died we're like we talking me like no no
we're not finish it and then we'll go
back to okay but I I never I never um I
never um what is it called
promote [ __ ] but I want to say the I am
rapport stereo podcast doing a live show
in New Orleans for all-star cold snap
next weekend next weekend
in New Orleans the 18th we're at live at
the joy theater oh [ __ ] son and the live
shows are good you know you guys will
definitely inspired us with the live
show yeah so if you're in New Orleans
you down there for all-star break the I
am Rapoport stereo pot which can they
get the tickets at www.wku.edu/oucampus
what excuse me
you didn't have any [ __ ] issues you
sit down in the guest seat sit down in
the get sea sick that we flowers not
happy man your lace started sit down in
the guess seat look tell us what your
issues are Nitin you're gonna make I
come on come on come on three TV shows
it okay as you know right okay
and sometimes scheduling can be happy in
this chair for cuz you're you can't just
pull your way into my tell you you're a
bigger yeah I don't know how I'm gonna
get you out you're a guest today where's
the camera
this kind of [ __ ] this is this is I've
never been more disrespected in my life
I've had a rough day I had to work
scheduling shoes I got a live show in
San Francisco and I have to shoot the
same day okay what was your say be
rapper time I like how's the schedule
good out like yeah what was the schedule
you do not set a lot yet your volt so
like tell me what this guy [ __ ] on my
Mannie cuz he still doesn't work on me
anymore no now what I do is set people
in they go your call times nine it's not
like getting calm like I listen I got
this thing like yeah they don't care
what's your schedule by the way by the
way you're hurting yourself by showing
up because I wonder where I reminded be
shop that the highest-rated fighter in
the kid episode is what what episode I
don't want if you say it don't it who
are you he's totally my you do the
numbers oh you do the run the numbers
but the highest-rated fighter in the cab
without it you don't come on my podcast
you start talking about how you get
higher rated Raptors you rap I'm not
here rappers take it oh what am i doing
you sit there in the guest spot for a
little bit yeah get out of my seat so
tell us why you're late and then we'll
see if alien I kinda grab you and
Hollywood awhile so you tell me I don't
think a [ __ ] me today what you tell
me the [ __ ] my Karen's resumes like
this it's a nice solid resume its
building it's big but but you busy man
but you we're talking about like no yeah
yeah then you go like that
it's like it's like it's like if we if
we if I pull down my loaf I'd be like
yeah Bryan Callen and then there's right
there's like it's like there's a little
noise Bryan Callen puts his loaf on the
table like that and then the gringo
mandingo puts is this like UK the Krag
thing good
you caught the grand you caught although
the heavy you like trap music
um challenge that grew you [ __ ] one
now I mean try and trap like in trap
like who am i [ __ ] with like right now
trap like yeah like your playlist of
traffic goddamn I mean my plants eat
it's all I would you listen to on the
way almost cool when it comes to trap
but would you listen to on the way over
you're just in general like yeah so that
you are the phone with your aging about
your schedule
I had my I had Asian stuff to do and cuz
I got I'm wanted I'm do you do your
eyebrows do it now I'm doing three TV
shows now what are the TV show you're
doing the Goldberg yeah own spin-off on
ABC will get you apart but mostly what
happens and then I got give you shot
that yet now I have a shot that yeah but
bout to about to and TV probably won't
be the same
doesn't matter and then what's the third
show did you make that up with the
Kingdom Kingdom I'm on Kingdom that's
the one Yap I like that show that's the
guy oh that actor I like a girl what
Frank Grillo that's the guy you you
[ __ ] him right he you bet him [ __ ] you
in here to say that he's no he's been
talking about Frank Carillo I didn't
know it Frank Grillo its grill don't say
gorilla it's Colonel Carrillo yes it
right I was learned he should be you
should be
you let him I don't do that man he's my
good buddy
and don't say that but he's like has a
[ __ ] man crazy I never said my gosh
Frank you know he's good-looking he's an
ass kicker he's gonna be a big star but
like he's a good-looking he's got a
great jawline like he'll [ __ ] kick
anybody's I'm like okay you know Frank
Carillo I'm like you just told me about
him yesterday Frank has he been on the
show gorilla yeah you not even
considered guest of the year all right
take it easy no I'm just saying like
okay but don't be competitive here he's
not Michael Rapaport on the mic we'll
put it down but I'd like but Frank
yo fire your publicist fire your manager
you hire a brother walking talking no
[ __ ] boy [ __ ] man [ __ ] man [ __ ] Mick is
your calf is you all know you know what
though I like that you said boy because
I got such a youthful Peter Pan vibrator
fit you do it he's be vibrancy there is
no Peter Pan yes vibrancy is what comes
to your mind when you look
yes vibrancy yes that's that's what
comes to my mind so anyway um I'm pretty
down with most of the current trends
right now I won't tell the bumps um mean
goes who bump a little 221 Savage I love
this when we went to Atlanta
front row Magic City you guys go to
Magic City hell [ __ ] yeah maybe we did
maybe we did it helped I would love to
see him in one of them spot I'm W to the
white well huh hey rap you know it's ass
yeah it's straight talker I want to get
paid today in cash for the ladies
because you said it well do I need to
show the Texas dude we got a guy I have
to go soon but I need to get paid look
for it because I haven't been paying the
back we're gonna bail be I have a
t-shirt for you I'm gonna thank you
I mean I got the gringo mandingo that's
a dope shirt are you soft yeah not like
those like t-shirts yeah double X cuz I
know your true goon I know you want to
wear it like it's like and I got this
text from the Backstreet Boys
this is dope butter soft iron rapport
t-shirt the gringo mandingo edition cuz
you are a true gringo mandingo it has
nothing to do with physics in essence
why do you write this to me what that
what I write a before this the text I
get cuz I know he's gonna do the part
what why do I get three texts all
separate coming a [ __ ] brother 9:30 a.m.
not true okay boom then I get gonna take
you real early real nice never said that
I don't respond never said that - he
waits then I get another I got full
balls and a nice pipe never said finally
I go well no it's
I'm not into that never say then he goes
and I get another one this is yeah true
watches yeah 9:30 take a shower I don't
respond again I get I don't know what
victim he's like he's like the person
I'm feeling I'm trying to make him go
away I get this I just not true people I
get this text it stands on what I'm
saying clean it I said that I go I won't
and now you go yeah just clean it bro
come on man I want to take take it clean
to make it messy brother I know I said
that I don't ask for a lot
true and then I get I ignore that and
then I got another one clean to dirty I
never said that you are you you sexually
that sexual terrorism really that's not
[ __ ] true sexual true I want to make
sure that that's not true it's text
terrorism and I could have you I can
actually see you for assault for that
and I just read it and we have a public
record of it right now it's but it's not
true so that's not true I don't want you
to say that I have a reputation to me
this is no no hey you touching me you
you have never stopped working
nah your show a BTS you the new edition
with new edition you know BT you know
that channel of black entertainer Thomas
um I'm in the black culture yeah but you
know it but that was shoe is it the
biggest show on beat it I'd be 20
million 20 million was huge it was
choose that way when I saw it was
because they were at what award show
were that no they had they did the whole
date the round yeah they did any or to
[ __ ] kid they showed like a clip of
it I see [ __ ] rap like I played I
played there's a male drag man and you
drain them for every [ __ ] away
really that's real life I totally have
you seen it's like right this man new
edition oh no this new edition knew his
boy no but knew it boys and them was
produced by one of the guys in new
edition but it's new edition we said it
four times before you said just to show
he doesn't listen to a [ __ ] word he's
just waiting like we said the new
edition movie the new edition was the
best and he goes woods boys to men I
thought new edition was a new edition of
the movie I'm sorry no but anyway it was
cool I was glad I did it I'm so uncool
and and I got the live show get said
where's the live show let's just see if
Brian was listening I know you could say
where's my live show coming up live show
my Rappaport live show what's it what
state
what's it what state is it in doesn't
know [ __ ] you at all know this
valley right doesn't listen it's in the
Pacific Northwest they're coming up this
Saturday the joycie yes you have yes
5:30 great New Orleans before the slam
dunk contest I am Rappaport toward comm
you do anything at the all-star game are
you involved in I'm doing the video I'm
doing a little bit
I'm do I'm doing a little I have to
leave a racket I'm doing it a little bit
what's great well we're supposed to be
down there when I
any more risk was to be down there to do
a show yeah not a live show which was do
that show hot ones hot ones okay but I'm
in Nashville you should be on there I
with the wings were rescheduled
okay the wings I did it you know I was
the number one guest on that all right
relax bro how hot were those wings no I
will carry hottest [ __ ] we're witness to
it I think it more first five six you're
gonna be like this is are they and then
it gets into like there was a house
there was actually point where I I like
I like like it was almost like you got
punched in the face like I was like like
that hot cuz I did some homework I watch
it and you'll see key and peele doing it
and the what keys like oh you're still
interview he's like huh give me such a
fun show but I literally like it felt
like I was like like that like that did
you get um did your mouth swell up are
you okay nothing swell up what it was it
like when you pooed it was all good man
but I but it honestly felt like I had
gotten like literally smacked habanero
sauce or some July voting member right
goes pepper let me answer the question
see again he's not even listening to
like the fact that he asked me a
question it's a good show I like doing
it I am the number one guest there's
been bigger Kevin Hart's been on alert
as Lord I think my [ __ ] was a little bit
more entertaining that he's a great
Kevin Hart well I'm saying like I didn't
win guest of the year 2015-2016 and now
I've laid that I've laid the lovely just
good say that you won 2017 no disrespect
this comedian
yeah Larry people decide well that's
what we're gonna do let the people
decide but don't start you're casting
yourself already as the winner and
that's not cool I'm sure I'm a little
cocky and won two years in a row as a
track record like last year I came in in
July and you guys look good this would
did it and who's the female comedian she
was on you guys said she had just been
on the the writer and Liza's we know
Whitney coming you guys like what she
was great I was like Whitney's great I
said but I'm here now you hear so like a
woman I want to get paid yes disappearo
hey man how much on your way out see see
there are cost yeah do I have to pay for
parking
nope they Valdai at the front okay okay
you're in the new studio yeah funds have
changed okay fine alright yeah well we
appreciate coming on man
I appreciate it anytime yeah great we
appreciate you having me and Brian on
yours because it's so cool that you
always hit us up you know I know what by
the way that it's me I feel like I feel
like [ __ ] amazing mission son I feeI
I mean I had grant Brendan on we talked
about the lake for a Kimbo Slice and and
you know we've we've done [ __ ] and again
the highest-rated do the math a janae
the highest the highest-rated fighter in
the kid was actually fighter and
Rappaport I don't like this
I don't like that's a [ __ ] fact fact
I don't like this [ __ ] so I want
that on the Internet
but you are a liar I'm happy about the
sign off you know I [ __ ] with you hard
body karate any time you guys want me
you guys are gonna do some reads do some
[ __ ] talk about gonna make some money
I'll finish the show I have to use the
bathroom and I have to go are you about
them too yeah Michael Rapaport are you
gonna pause it later Michael Rapaport
2017 guests of the I'm not saying that
you know these [ __ ] hipsters winter
you know like we were all the same
there's gentler genderless no or not cuz
if I pull this loaf out first are you
gonna be shocked okay exactly I blow oh
the [ __ ] gringo mandingo we're
talking right here I thought now it's my
piece like that so what yeah that's
that's what makes you even more
mesmerized right but like we should
celebrate our differences and accept
like we want to be genderless I know but
then then didn't come talk to me I I
don't get the big deal like with with
women not being a Navy SEAL okay cool
just that's not for you men can't do a
lot of [ __ ] women can do who gives a
[ __ ] a lot actually comes to physical
attributes men are just better stronger
stay stronger well they're faster
stronger but you're seeing better see
I'm trying to protect you from the
[ __ ] I'm trying to hit there's a
Linda Felina [ __ ] done yes just our
Lena [ __ ] Dunning I'm saying when it
comes to Navy SEALs the guiltiest white
person on the planet do you know anybody
else was more white guilt and Lena
Dunham that that should be the Clippers
do you know any white person on the
planet Earth with more white guilt than
Lena [ __ ] dumb done him the woman who
had a show on the air for six years
bring her she had a showing
it's called girls that took place in
Brooklyn with no black people in it
this is the guiltiest white lady in the
world in her didn't she blocked you on
she blocked me up why did she block you
I'm so hard in the paint at her not
naive but but just like in that kind of
way I don't like talk about like no you
know like looks or anything like that
that's not that's not my thing
yeah it's just like she liked the voice
the fact that she she's anointed herself
the voice of her generation to me is you
can do better you can get a better voice
here there's better voices you know I'm
surprised by and I saw you ranting us at
those brilliant but those white
supremacist then neo-nazis I can't go
don't go call that I can't believe that
[ __ ] still exist I was like what the
[ __ ] you know like if you really want to
get it poppin wired like if you want to
get it poppin why are you doing out
there going you know where to find a
once let me know I'll go into Brooklyn
new Newport News they were down in
Virginia go to Browns you know let me
know how it works out for you see how
that works out there with that Bush and
did they go in Atlanta with their
[ __ ] skinny jeans like like the ones
that that were on camera like there was
like a couple of them like there's one
guy with sunglasses I think it was a
blind neo-nazi he's up there doing this
[ __ ] covering his [ __ ] finger you
know but like they like where are these
guys during the daytime like can we pull
their Instagram like I want to go see
him like yo what's really good man yeah
I know doing this Heil Trump [ __ ] I mean
Trump you know is a real [ __ ] boy I'm
Jewish you know a real [ __ ] boy is Jared
Kushner he's an Orthodox Jew Sunday
dinner with Donald Trump you're not
getting into a fight with your
father-in-law shame on you you [ __ ]
panty wearing pampering taking
[ __ ] Jared Kushner is a [ __ ]
made and he's a mother [ __ ] he's an
Orthodox Jew Jesus I guarantee you he
bleeds every month like a little [ __ ]
[ __ ] he is a [ __ ] [ __ ]
these people are saying hail Trump and
you say nothing you have nothing to say
about that you're an Orthodox Jew your
father is the for your father-in-law's
that easy is the president of United
States you got nothing to say
shame on you [ __ ] you dip the
face dumb [ __ ] I can't stand
that [ __ ] that's it yeah you've
been here for at all what's up you've
been here fertile visit the whole show
it's it's it's it's August it is you
want to give me the guest of the year
bail now should I just come back in
January
well help I have to get it made no it's
a little while okay I'm done I'm [ __ ]
done be done man [ __ ] out of your paint
on homeboys everything I have you can
you know you're coming to clean my house
in and I want it done by the end of the
month we're not like August and early
September
I'll give you September I'll give you
some to pay off [ __ ] dad let me send
your dick pigs get over your whole thing
watch the watch the smut off you from
that fight and then you're coming to my
crib you will don't you brother thing
Jay you and Jay you can do [ __ ] I
want you guys in Palma now I'm
videotaping the whole thing I might have
some pom-poms there to put it both
another [ __ ] I love it man well the
officer you can find you [ __ ] all
over big three Michael wrap - [ __ ]
policy football fantasy football this
book has balls calm pre-cum
we'll do it with Brian he'll talk about
your book critique it you're the best
brother he'll talk about like how he
read it like Brian Council would like
probably the biggest fake reader on the
planet the biggest if you name any book
girl I read that [ __ ] he didn't read
[ __ ] with it with the he's got like a DD
on steroids monster [ __ ] no he's
sitting down reading here's ago I read
that in The Times and The Wall Street
Journal [ __ ] I saw the same
tweet you favorite encourages like whole
I read Dostoevsky no what no you didn't
where's the books you didn't read
Shannon I think he reads his [ __ ]
scripts I did a movie without a book in
his house [ __ ] his own scripts he
shows up you [ __ ] learns his lines it
shows up there now you liked it you
liked and I don't want it but you like
to [ __ ] well my question is did you ask
Kellyanne Conway did you get anything
hey those bags aren't under her eyes
because she's getting a lot of sleep all
right well keeping her up
she was I saw this [ __ ] ice on his
beluga whale and I said I saw this this
Narwhal with the huge unicorn then I
said that they put it up my ass and
massaged my prostate oh ho that's a
really good that's what I did with the
polar bears that's really good Wow man
this has become a very strange story
thank you for sharing it though and we
really appreciate know what else is
[ __ ] new oh hey I want to say I want
to tell your audience to go head over to
youtube youtube / Will Sasso TV and we
have a short that I made with yours and
mine honey
Thank You Kyle follow me I have to be
honest that that is that is a social
media love it
I tweeted out I tweeted it out yeah I
[Laughter]
came over I thank you hyeyeon that one
yeah it's got a special it's called
Brian's tweet retweet yeah it is
hilarious a lot thanks Lady Gaga because
you have 20 min what do you what do you
find yourself youtubing most of the time
besides polar bears and all sorts of
well one thing I like to do is you do
anything and you just put ytp in front
of it which means youtube poop have you
done this no I sure I'm always down with
the kids and what they're what they're
doing I have something yeah you too
ytp what's this stand for
if YouTube poop so any version kids have
rieta tudeng on the internet so if you
if there's any subject you like for
example last night's joint address you
just put YT p and then joint address
pretty soon people will have made wacky
little videos about that ah and the
editing is crazy and it's called youtube
poop ah anyway so please youtube poop
follow me go to youtube.com slash will
sasso TV and take follow me and Marshall
cooks a hell of a director anyway yeah
we made this stupid [ __ ] thing it's
funny though it's a lot of fun I really
enjoy I wanted to it's a satire it's
about a guy and he's got a wife and kids
but he's addicted woefully addicted to
all the social media apps and it's about
that and it's something relevant right
now that's trying to make it you know
make something that's like you know
funny but sad and shows sort of how
people are are you doing well no I was
telling him earlier it's great because
I'm addicted to I'm still addicted to
dough and cheese so really nothing gets
closer to that yeah close um I might
addicted to my phone yeah when I don't
have my phone with me I do reach for it
feel weird right yeah it feels weird
I do yeah you know I like to check my
Instagram feed I realized not too long
ago that I need to either find out who
among my real people in my life are on
Instagram and add them to or just stop
looking at Instagram because here's this
person and here's that guy and there's
this you're all have a person I don't
really have a personal thing with or at
least not anymore and it's you're just
I'm still peering into your life your
voice Stone Cold Steve Austin was on the
show yesterday and he was saying how
awesome he's asking about snapchat he
was asking about yeah he's like should I
go on snapchat
I need snapchat like they got all them
[ __ ] filters you can make your face
look like a little [ __ ] girl with the
shiny [ __ ] diamonds and [ __ ]
you can even have a [ __ ] clown face
or a [ __ ] dog with where your tongue
comes out he's if y'all want to see
Stone Cold Steve Austin as a dog a cute
dog with his tongue flapping out give me
a hell yeah
what oh yeah Brian don't do that while
I'm doing it I'm just doing a little bit
of a bit but we like to hey that's what
being killers we fed yeah bit killer
even I'm I'm Steve cold Stone Cold Steve
all
stone Steve hold is ice-cold that's hot
stone it's not bad that is pretty good
you know we do on 10-minute podcasts
I'll do an impersonation and then Tommy
just doesn't want to hear it so he just
goes I'm shitty so and so so he does
shitty Hulk oh [ __ ] it doesn't sound
like him at all it's actually my
favorite thing and then it's like 2:00
p.m. and then chatter I'm good to talk
and it's way but yeah don't ever don't
do you want to do some impersonal yeah I
do
would you like to yes okay let's play a
little game all right you give me an
impersonation
maybe something you've never heard me do
before maybe maybe something that I
can't do and then I'll do it and then
you do the shavers and I'm all the Tommy
black I'm pretty good man that's tough
you know what let me you've done it but
I'd like to compare the two okay I'd
like just Trump let's start easy let's
start easy with Trump you're already
making the face because you don't know
what you're doing yes don't [ __ ] like
talk about drink don't judge my [ __ ]
will that will it meet just so I'm not
biased me chin and agent a will vote
super I love it okay here's here's a
little bit we're gonna yeah we're gonna
just do something a little simple saying
yeah okay let's paint a scenario let's
pretend we're in the Oval Office yeah
we're just having a little fun Donald
Trump let's say he's watching me and
Kellyanne Conway he would say yeah
bending over and [ __ ] hard will now
you say it I'm not gonna say something
that why Noah sahjhan is okay because
and I really mean this it's cheating
that's actually not bad and it's mean
it's not bad yeah that's actually pretty
good
yeah I have
nothing to do with Russia Russia Russia
you gotta put a little rest I had
nothing to do with the Russian Russia
say China
I have no whisper China China no whisper
China China but make it readily China
China China China China that's pretty
good it's not bad
that's really good I'm a brilliant mimic
keep going what else we'll do another
one
I am Ray Romano I've never done it's a
relevant automation that kids need to
hear like my brother hi well we found
ray my brother's tall my brother my
brother's tall ice tells me what to do
with my my parents are here it's been a
long time since I've ever I've never
tried that's terrible don't stop back
it's so bad hold on it's it can you do
criminal fraud it's similar to say John
Denver John Denver now Linda Ronstadt
now Linda Ronstadt yay [ __ ] sad it's
so sad for me to do that's when you know
you get hermit B frog I am permit yeah
[ __ ] I am Kermit the Frog I didn't grow
up with these guys you didn't grow up
why you study ray well let me give you
this Clint Eastwood oh let him go first
we're not doing no Clint Eastwood you
can't hey I think he yeah Diane Diane
ain't much of a living boy yeah Diane
Diane ain't much of a living
alright this one's on you right give me
your best Russian will end on this give
me your best Robin Russian Russian I
would like to do John Malkovich in
rounders oh my god one of my favorite
chick chick chick pay him Pierre that me
and his many that's pretty [ __ ] good I
like to do just a Russian but I have to
think about what kind of rock oh very
good
give me a Siberian KGB operative
deep just in a snow cover inside you are
you are here not for Wallace but because
you got enemy of the state
all right Dracula because I was
pretending to be Dracula but in fact I'm
from Russia you must die because what a
mere poop yes it's pretty good it's
pretty good yeah I'm very good
impressions are stupid
I like Dracula I've always liked I've
always wanted to be I've always wanted
to say this and I don't know how to do
it but when the wolves howl we're gonna
howl and I want you to say ah the
children of the night what sweet music
they make so as Dracula as Dracula and
I'd like you to be involved in this too
way I'm howling well yo how and if you
want to do Dracula and try your hand at
Dracula you can as well hear it so
beautiful and then you say ah the sweet
children of the night what's the second
part what sleep music what sweet music
they play right they make they make yeah
but do it with a little more relish ah
they sweet other sweet children I the
children of the night what sweet music
they make
ah they children and the children of the
night what sweet music they make it's a
little yeah come on come on kid give
Arnold Dracula this is my biggest role
to date almost watching the history well
let's cut to a clip let's cut to a clip
oh yeah you guys have a clip of Arnold
Schwarzenegger's drag yeah you know tell
us about working with Arnold
Schwarzenegger and Arnold Schwarzenegger
Dracula it must've been amazing it was
really or the wolf right I was the wolf
and you have that scene where you guys
communicate me you know I got to say he
did a great job he was he was scary and
I believe drank believable he was very
disciplined why we cut to a clip here we
are here's a clip of Arnold
Schwarzenegger in Arnold
Schwarzenegger's Dracula these sweet did
children of the night
yeah what sweet music did it make yeah
you look so much range on this is most
like yes just out of the Bob dude you're
like was half Wardrobe in half leg was
that like that Andy Serkis CGI yes and
Bob you look amazing how about this we
found a clip of Donald Trump back in
1987 what when he wanted to be an actor
I don't know if you ever saw that well
they Dracula that's right he was in that
dancers in Donald Trump's critic and we
have a clip where the guy says would you
like some wine and and Donald as Dracula
said no I never I never drink vine and
it's really okay look yeah have a look
so why don't we cut to that clip that's
all he says though count would you like
some wine no I never drink wine
and they're not the best scariest I know
the scariest sorry like Donald Inc
commit to the roll you guys also have a
clip of is this true Hulk Hogan he was
due ww that's like expendable for nine
yeah he plays Dracula Dracula it was
like right in between no-holds-barred
and suburban demands reacted to the
wolves again and what was the line well
it was are the children of the night
yeah what sweet music they make I can't
wait to get my hands on them oh okay
that's right got that yeah okay I want
to cut to the clip yeah
yeah yeah dude Wolfe roller are the
children of the night dude
what sweet music they make brother yeah
dude yeah brother would you like some
lime count no dude I never drink wine
brother milk is for babies awful Alfred
you got a drink beer dude or unless
you're making a protein shake brother
crack a few eggs and they're awful
Alfred and then you could drink it back
we put a banana in there we put this
special green powder dude and then any
blood and then the blood I want to drink
your protein blood Wow yeah it's really
really good yeah thanks that was really
amazing let's have a look at this clip
far the children of the night what sweet
music they make
I forgot about Ray Romano playing drags
my wolf brother is very tall and my wolf
parents are here and my wolf wife wants
to go to the ballet but I want to watch
football really good Wow yeah Romano and
also really relevant impersonations to
that all the youngsters yeah okay all
right man but don't get all physical
with myself rough you up a little bit
rough yup that's so what are you doing
besides a enough all night and drinking
tequila here I'll [ __ ] mess sounds
like a good time though I don't drink
yeah take your sunglasses off Noah leave
a loss instant I know your eyes would
kill with whatever you bid man if it's
Izzy I was on the road there water the
jug of water tries to be crate always
has the jug allow much water do you
drink of death and why are you sweating
I don't know it's [ __ ] hot out there
I'm wearing two shirts and a hat I'm a
big guy I have a slight salt imbalance
coupled with a possible thyroid problem
what you guys leave me in here I was
talking about your [ __ ] set if you
can call something a set yeah it's in a
you know a room that the fourth kid gets
in a fit big for a twin size bed hey
don't be do do not be a disrespectful
I'm just saying you got all sorts of
[ __ ] yeah all right you I did your
10-minute podcast yeah destroyed was oh
yeah it's by the way I am it did the 10
minute podcast yeah thank you so much
for sitting in and I was amazing but
here's the thing
well you you still in that dumb basement
yeah in my house changed a [ __ ] thing
well I gotta keep your voice down and to
do my podcast all you got to do is go
downstairs so who's the domain although
this room is way bigger than the room we
do the 10 minute podcast in and mine
could use a lick of paint I feel happy
yeah I'm happy to be here I'm always
happy to speak to your audience
tung city yourself city yourself one of
the family we've taken to you so strong
as Claire we're going to get along very
good and we're song City so Annie is
that from Annie
no it's from Oliver Twist the furniture
you haven't got much to spare who cares
what I love yeah
alright good strata who's nice yeah yeah
no I've never been down there after me
what do they call they call lobsters
bugs out there yeah they do while
they're in the boat of Resident shut the
[ __ ] up about animals I'm just talking
about Australian well and he was so
happy
why do we call them bugs cuz yeah I'm
tell you this right now yeah yeah yeah
yeah watch your tongue
okay what's gonna happen what are you
gonna do use some of that boxing you
been doing shut up Brian
will you fight Lisa give a [ __ ]
well well kind of see what I said to
[ __ ] Chris D'Elia
serious man yeah who who's that
listen if you're feeling froggy you got
a head and leap all right now you're
looking for trouble can you be in
disrespect downing water-table hey
trouble here
okay drop here let me tell you something
what you remember a while back speaking
to him in a podcast thank you for
sitting in for Tommy blotchy and
remember the time that you wrote a
letter to Chad Kultgen
because years ago we're working on a
project and Chad and I was training in
mixed martial arts yes and Muay Thai yes
let's be let's be clear I'm I was a guy
in his you know mid 30s training in my
time
yeah just kind of rolling around you
know just having my trainer Harold
Dimond you know you would kick the bag
and some nice Harold diamond would say
that kick right there would split
somebody's liver yeah yeah yeah sure
good times brought the thing about it is
I was just like a big you know just a
big sloppy fat dude in the gym don't be
that mean yourself I'm not I'm a
pragmatist I'm a realist and you wrote a
letter to Chad cos Chad said if I had a
year tune I'll be able to put will and
really choke and you explain to him the
difference between a dog and a bear you
wrote him a female essay well he wrote
your trainer he wrote I wrote my Bolton
who's a writer and is about five seven
and though he's not a five-pin he's not
five ten yeah it's a ridiculous thing to
say no but I'm
I'll go with will on this cuz you're
always fine everytime seven without
question there's no no probably about
510 okay let's see five nine he's five
nine 171 65 okay I put about 185 now
your stop just walking around
you stopped me to me I mean any regular
guy and not a regular got baseball
played some base hell of a baseball
player is the thick dude he played me
stormed out school he played baseball up
until last year and he said I think I
could take well if I trained and I had
to explain to him that that just
wouldn't happen you wrote him in the
essay I wrote Chatham is a nothing else
no he wrote him a long essay come out do
yoga in the bed Ottoman Baron that he
posted on his website because it was it
was it was well respond the same way the
guy was dead serious that he could be
with yeah dad is always serious
take a minute I I haven't met this guy
no I don't believe so he's a he's
fantastic writer producer and he his
contention was he wasn't saying this
would definitely be what happened but he
said he goes I think if I had a year to
Train and I put on what he said
something ridiculous he said like 20
pounds of Moses crisis he writes yeah
but he's just yeah and he'd never had
any training so he's just a big fight
fan you know he's a huge MMA fan and he
also said he could you could potentially
beat a whale in a fight well if I got if
I got my fingers deep in its I I feel
like it would be like and then I would
kind of technically win the fight
so his point was thought he could take
willed like I had to explain him that
will is if well was motivated and strong
will would world's very hard to hurt for
a guy's never really punched him you
know and I said also that will want it
to he said you're a prideful man but you
need to understand the way the universe
works a dog ain't beat beating a bear a
silverback ain't here in a peep out of a
chimp either yeah not a peep and didn't
get through to this game yeah yeah Chad
said uh you know I'm telling you very
realistic I think I didn't think
in but a lot of this stuff don't save
enough reddit 50 times because dub
Davidoff couldn't believe that his
friend Bryan Callen would take this much
time to break down yeah the shoe man
let it stay but one of the things I
always say about you is that when guys
when guys who are regular guys have
played some sports and have some pride
will say well how would that would you
do against Brendan I go are you asking
really how you would do against Brendan
and then they go yeah I go what you need
to know about him and it's not it's a
hard thing for you to hear as a man is
that if Brendan wanted to [ __ ] you he
could [ __ ] you it wait that's so we're
not beating us all but no but that's all
very important thing to understand
there's there's BP somebody help and
then somebody who can truly impose their
will on you well if [ __ ] look and I
appreciate that you're a bottom-line guy
and when someone is coming to you with a
you know question they're sort of
beating around the bush saying when you
you zone right and you go I know what
you want to know you want to know if you
could what you would do with my
preaching and they all go it and then
you just cut the conversation off with
he'll [ __ ] you so that they stop it's
abrasive it's a little trick but here's
here's where here's where this is story
that I got this from from an interesting
experience I'm in fear school in New
York City you've never been in New York
shut up that's Jay I know come on come
on let me just get through so you've
never been on a [ __ ] cruise nobody
goes on cruises guy nobody wants to old
people can do it every story on the
truck did when I was a kid I was in try
worked at the nursery when [ __ ] late
eighties early night I don't give I was
[ __ ] into all the glanced around you
don't know how to drive a try
Datsun truck would you let me just some
people either in New York and ballet
school I'm in I'm in theater school and
there was a guy who was a giant do any
[ __ ] who who is no he was he happened to
have been a professional ballet dancer
and had never fought but he was I you
know me I have I've spent enough time
and looking at men and doing sports like
wrestling whether it was talking where I
know I can see how much lovely to see if
you were to fight somebody how much that
would be to manage if they were
motivated to fight and if you're a
regular guy those a guy was built like
me but not really had never really done
any sports he was built like me but he
lifted weights cool he would do yeah he
would do bench press and he would do
pulldown yeah regular guy but never done
any sports and wasn't so athletic but he
was kind of amply sized he was a little
bigger than me maybe but whatever and he
decided that because this guy they were
doing a scene now in theater school and
I don't know if you've ever had this
experience but in theater school scenes
can get very charged and emotional
sometimes
as they say you're making believe but
your body doesn't forget that you're
making believe in your body takes over
and they only do charged work oh no I
would define well that way all right
what's like working will charged yeah
yeah I only do intense work so fired kid
3d that time was I said what they said
how was it with will on said I went
charged charged intense yeah you ever
lick a nine-volt no yeah just had a nine
volt to you I have it burned you to
charge do the car battery and keep it
there for a few minutes anyway sorry
going okay
so this guy what they're doing a scene
and and it's an improv scene and this
guy starts to get macho with the big
ballet dancer who was not gay but very
kind of like you know he would wear nude
so good they don't know he yeah maybe
yeah you know and I was watching this
and he started to shove the ballet
dancer and the ballet dancer who was big
and Germanic and just you know just all
raw bones and
had been dancing his whole life goes hit
let's just say the guy's name is Chris
he was Chris stop Chris stop just broke
the scene and said the wrists yeah Chris
kept getting in his face and pushing him
playing the role yeah but he was he was
trying to alpha dog and burn everyone in
front of everybody and he was doing it
in a sloppy kind of uncool aggressive
way and he kept going Chris I said stop
and finally he tried to put the ballet
dancer in a headlock and I actually came
at him and the ballet dancer flipped
there was a sweat chance on his face he
switched and he went the way a big
brother does to a little brother he
grabbed him around the body brought him
to the ground and got on top of him and
just got on top of him and God is like
almost like an a half guard kind of got
his leg and pushed him down and held him
down and then put his arms under his
neck and squeezed him into a spot into
his chest and said and the cast Chris
start going get out they got me he's
like calm down calm down and go and he'd
hold him until Chris started to cry he'd
never been he'd never been in that
situation he'd never been physically
imposed upon by another man if I was
like that crying I get up and go and see
[Laughter]
[Applause]
just go well charge
well Joe got a rocking right you've
gotta realize this was a kid who'd never
been in theater school this is all new
emotional work a lot of boys grow up
especially in this country where emotion
and all that [ __ ] is not comfortable
we're being imposed upon if you've never
done sports is really new like if you've
never done a sport never been labeled
level in the playing field and somebody
shows you that and you're in your 20s
yeah and you've never had no brothers
assists yeah very weird to not get that
going if you're you know I mean just if
you played contact sports of [ __ ] starts
happening literally eight you right away
but there
he'd never done that but you don't have
a brother who in my case used to say
meatball boy and fold my nose to my to
my knees yeah he's 9 years older than me
and he would grab me under the knees I'm
like you need that stuff - yeah a 4 5 6
a 10 years old ah
chubby 10 year old still doing meatball
boy yeah how about the time that his
body with an island like some people
have that body where they're like no
Island Bob no one's ever done that to
them yeah and so that's a rebel boy
that's a crisis at 23 and somebody's
holding you down you can't breathe in
front everybody and you literally can't
move from under a man yeah he so I never
forgot this my teacher who is this
wonderful big gay man with the biggest
mustache in the world who is still one
of my heroes and he changed my life and
he looked at him and he goes Chris as he
was crying they stopped it you go Chris
what happened here besides the fact that
you almost got [ __ ] he said that and
that was I never forgot a reality check
it was a reality check and there are
there are those reality checks in life
in general you ever see somebody who's
never had to work out super hard and
they're just so out of breath it's like
what did Vince Lombardi say fatigue
makes cowards of us all yeah first time
you've ever been pushed to that degree
I'm sure as an athlete when you guys put
yourself to that or football or whether
it would MMA I'm sure you saw guys break
whoo yeah right everyone has a pretty
cuz they were in a place where they
didn't know how to get out of it that's
just tough work you're gonna have a
breaking point you know the giant German
actor that does ballet is not breaking
anyone I know but yeah yeah your story
kind of you know yeah it's I mean you
can tell me your story you know I'll
listen to your stories but it's a little
disrespectful come Ryan hey but here's
what you're making an absolutely great
point and it all comes back to the dog
and the bear the silverback in the chimp
whatever you want to say and this is why
when you are a guy who you know is you
and you're what five 170 right how you
characterize doesn't matter because
boxing and [ __ ] and the reason it made
me laugh from the bottom of my gut
is that if you ever step to me give a
[ __ ] if we're in the theater class yeah
I'll give a [ __ ] if we're on a cruise to
New York
where we are especially respectful I'll
fold you a full jet no yes and I'll toss
you on top of the tallest building I see
no have a look around don't laugh at
that if there's a two-story building the
seams here what are we on the third
floor here yeah so this has got three
floors this place yeah all the all the
places in this whole complex three
pretty cool stuff yeah there's lots of
great [ __ ] outside there's as I was
walking in I saw a food truck yeah
everyone was ordering stuff yeah careful
now
looks like it's a good thing yeah if we
were out there and I was in line and I
was like yeah hi chicken Caesar no
croutons and then you walked up and you
shoved me out of the way and you would
three food store cool and I would just
fold you and turn you around and I would
start spit and I go there it it and it's
like oh there's one and three stories up
[ __ ] you you'd wake up gravel rash on
the roof just crumpled up against an air
conditioning unit what the [ __ ] happens
it grabbed you you'll get gravel rash
[Laughter]
they'll be up there tar in the gravel
with their hot mops and you'll go watch
you got a look you're hot it's hot up
there you got some tar on guitar you got
gravel ratchet in public yes little bony
in my pants yeah a little [ __ ] a little
[ __ ] in your pants listen I appreciate
what you're saying and I get it I'm not
a regular guy I got a lot of tricks here
yeah that's the same thing as Chad
I'll get will in the wind again I've
been sitting down the punches lately
doing a lot of sparring a measuring
distance who's the guy that I say you
can all unequivocally I always give you
props and I say if that goes to a fight
an organized fight and I would love to
see it happen maybe we can set up some
sort of charity I know what's happening
Brian's taking that [ __ ] dudes head
off who's that who do I say that about
CM Punk
okay I don't know Brooks yes I always
say that Brian at 50 years old yeah
you'll be able to [ __ ] you'd be able
to you'd give a CM Punk a false sense of
security
he'd come at you and then you'd throw
under them box and Bob spin kicks like
you do on Instagram yeah get him into
that gravel rash
get them gravel round nothing rash you
know get him in the hot mops in the
black toilet tonight he's gonna fight
again huh probably come on that'll be
fun it's a nice compliment yeah careful
so what I'm gonna say is I'll kick his
ass and your [ __ ] that hey I'll [ __ ]
both up
listen I'm oh hey how about this yeah
[ __ ] quote me
I'll only fight CM Punk if I'm fighting
Bryan Callen at the same time what do
you mean because I want to show people
the difference so I'm just a big what it
Brennan and you as I walk in here yeah
here he is a whites a albino Samoan the
shaved polar bear what does a polar bear
do there's a polar bear do any does he
do any mixed martial arts in LA does he
do any lifting wax no what does he do he
drags walruses up onto that's right he
lives he hunts and he lives yeah and
that's what I do I hunt and I live yeah
and it ain't a it's a it's a regular day
on the ice for me to drag CM Punk and
Bryan up out of the water onto my
iceberg and just pools and pools of
blood pools of blood regular that's
regular day on the ice I gotta eat what
am I gonna let Brian go because I'm
eating CM Punk no you killed I'll fight
CM Punk so long as I'm fighting bryan
callen handicap match okay that's who
won won and you guys got to wear
matching [ __ ] [ __ ] tag to you what
the [ __ ] where you and CM Punk now hey
will what was the tag team where they
had the shoulder pads and spikes on them
oh the road warriors yeah yeah yeah yeah
road warrior animal and road where what
I want
what a rush I'm wear what I want what we
need you to wear yeah no you guys yeah
you guys want to wear but I want you to
wear like yeah you guys are gonna wear
spiky shoulder pads but I want the
spikes digs no I want you guys in
matching like killer beez outfits like B
Brian Blair and joke around
CM Punk used to be a professional
wrestler and that's what I want you guys
it's just no it's just a singlet you
know it's just little de shorts at
stripe striped with the killer bees just
like bees like black and yellow and then
you know some cute knee pads and then
wings maybe at the back there are wings
if you want whatever some be wings yeah
yeah just for the entrance right and
then and then you guys get in the ring
and that's the only way I'll fight CM
Punk what are you sick of Theo von I'm
sick of celebrities telling people
political stuff Tom I thought the
basically the [ __ ] Academy Awards
yeah there's so much rich dude it's easy
to be nice in a theater when you're rich
dude yeah go to a poor theater dude hmm
people are humming usually a sister
hitting you in the back of the head with
something for nothing for you didn't do
anything I don't what grind your do but
yeah I mean it could be an urban girl or
your actual you know blood sister okay
have you been an urban theater I mean
it's just like hey just pop this black
couple was behind you just straight-up
talk oh yeah I guess like like there's
no movie there's no etiquette and I'm
not I'm not saying black people I'm
saying urban deer it's a mix I go this
one off yeah Heidi you you better hope
you better hope it's a 3d movie with all
out yeah it's interacting for a plot
your [ __ ] it's in our super far active
they're eating three [ __ ] yeah here
it's it's that's [ __ ] popcorn and
damn dog you see that [ __ ] bro yeah dude
is your movie theatre etiquette
oh dude a lot of black people and I will
say this cuz this is really factual and
I've spent a lot of time around you know
in the dark arts and I don't mean that's
not black people in general that's how
do you do that's black Matt is
everything black man yep you know I grew
up in a mixed neighborhood dude and
black people don't really know they
don't differentiate between
indoors and outdoors who do you mean
outdoors can be indoors dude
what do you mean outdoors can be indoors
black person you can put them outdoors
and you put them indoors same volume
levels same speed there's no inside
voice there's no there's zero and snow
and it killed me going to loose well
they just don't I don't believe in I
like a lot of structures and I don't
know if I don't want to say would work
but I want to say overall that they the
difference between indoors and outdoors
it when it comes from most credibly it's
so incredibly vaguely racist
they say that filter know what they say
when they're poor it's true and a lot of
people who are poor but it's a
socio-economic thing so a lot of people
that are poor a lot of times I guess
have to rely on each other like they
notice [ __ ] that that say rich people
wouldn't notice yeah because they have
to because the you you're kind of
relying on your neighbor on usually
sharing a bathroom there's a lot of
stuff people are on you and acquittals
people yeah you got any create sort of
this this feeling of competition we're
going to lower your voice when you're in
the mall in the theater right that's
what I'm hurt yeah yeah a lot of my
black friends even do not pry yeah they
don't have indoor voices what I'm trying
to say but if you're Horning maybe
you're sharper and you're here you're
just more you're hungrier well dude I'll
notice sometime my neighbor has a cat
right they got some kind of a white cat
yeah huge white I feel like a little too
white white people and out the
Illuminati well and sing and sing super
film and single freaking women who just
you know yeah the cat lady well I will
notice dude honestly and I don't do
morning masturbation thank God because I
think that is honestly fur forbidden
criminals do I can't imagine waking up
and just spraying out the beginning of
the day I would be heartbroken all day
and try it but I'll notice if I'd have
done that in the past that if I see my
neighbor's cat cuz my neighbors kind of
wait out there for me to come out of my
door and I don't know if they I don't
know what their behaviors are like in
their head but he will wait out there
for me to come out of my door and just
kind of see what my vibe is and I'll
notice I will feel more fear if I've
masturbated before I've left the house
when I see that animal then if I come
out I'm fired up and my nuts are full no
you know carrion like you come out with
a loaded gun so the cat determines your
day the cat how you react to the cat
like depending on how full your balls
are you're gonna react to that cat in a
different way well I've only rarely if I
ever masturbated in the morning you know
uh my habit happens at night and it's
just late at night and I just can't I
don't know what's wrong with me but if I
do it in the morning and I go outside I
notice that I feel inferior to that
animal whereas if I don't do it I don't
like barely even notice mm-hmm dude I
could not just only thing I could fight
man I'm a one kid attack me once in
school they can go really well I got a
tight bunch of dogs dogs that's a
different animal
yeah but literally the dog two of them
came back and attacked me on my birthday
again a year later on your birthday
swear to God when they come back they
came back like this fools birthday lets
you take any bites
oh yeah it's Rico bites once in the
hospital is my birthday I'm aroused
eleven years old and then at 12 years
old two of them came back and got me in
here like they know that's what I'm
saying man animals are insightful dude I
feel don't have any animals I don't have
any animals I'd like to get one one day
but I got to get a somebody to be around
the house and a teammate you know one
dog international but you know I need a
teammate zone to kind of help out and do
you mean a [ __ ] girlfriend sir yeah
probably that and there's there's
nothing going on there you got no no no
leads or nothing this is a cold case
I'll tell you so this is I mean I see my
problem is I don't want to grow up
sometimes and be an adult you know about
relationships so you know I'll be out
there either trying to skis around a
little bit and feeling a shame to myself
for doing that or I'll be trying to you
know actively pursue a woman but but I
won't want to
I have some commitment issues so in the
end it comes down to I gotta work on my
issues before I can get back you really
get in the game or maybe just haven't
met the right one connect I wanna make
you shut down
yeah and that's my looking for God if
you know the right one do you know I'm
saying drop her off over there on
greenfield app it's not easy to find the
right one in Los Angeles it is very hard
they don't make the right ones out here
very often especially in your in in this
best comedy business damaged goods man
this is like that back alley at a Costco
if you're a beautiful woman and you
don't want to have any really
responsibilities and you don't want to
work hard and you want to meet an older
man with money I don't try and get for
it I'm sorry oh yeah keep it down it's
true though but you it's tough to
compete with that
it's tough yeah oh dude it's tough when
like you know you're texting some girl
who's Steven Tyler's texting as well you
know and he gots a jet I don't have a
jet dude he got to jet I'm gonna sit
there and decide for forty minutes for
him to send the nicer uber to you dude I
knew a guy he used to pay Vietnamese
dudes come beat his ass dude for like a
thousand bucks yeah guys and just be as
those in the Hollywood Hills dude this
dude would pay these two Vietnamese
dudes drive up there five hundred each
and beat the [ __ ] out of them dude he's
like you just got off on it yeah just
got beat up and then I guess he'd just
lay there something would go to bed I
don't know I think he was here's what I
think I think he was doing bad business
dirty business and he felt bad about it
but he didn't feel like he was able to
stop doing the business because the
money was making so he needed some sort
of repercussion some sort of like like
yeah so so he would do it basically like
I well I'm gonna do this but yeah go and
whoop that ass yeah I need to get
doesn't make it right right doesn't make
it right but at least I'm like I'm I'm
getting my Halen prize yes at least
there's some repercussions for my
actions I'm paying a price so at least
then you could like you know send a mass
text to people you're [ __ ] over you
just lay in there bleedin a couple of
some of your money I made off of you if
you hadn't kinky [ __ ] like that ever in
your friends parties anything I feel
like you live a crazy life man no did I
grew up really in the you know
now there were a lot of diseases I did a
I did a I did a fundraiser last night I
was at a fundraiser for lymphoma right
and I've never even heard of it
comedy fundraiser yellow foam in
leukemia you know and I never even heard
of lymphoma you know and no offense if
anybody has lymphoma but I had um I grew
up around rabies was like the hottest
thing you get you know you'd be think
good a rabies get bit by a squirrel or
some [ __ ] where you're from
yeah [ __ ] that's from yeah there's a lot
of animal stood or cousin anybody that's
uh you know not taking good care of
themselves so they spend a lot of time
outdoors and you can to dead giveaways
that people have rabies are if they're
afraid to drink water and if they're
kind of playing hide-and-go-seek by
themselves a little bit like if you see
them kind of yeah except them and that's
uh that's rabies rabies yeah you don't
know beat it times you die yeah and you
can look that up dude I don't know what
just quote actually you can Bobby just
close your eyes and no you know and now
they work that's the dark arts boy I
fell asleep in Smashing Pumpkins concert
that's a great concert yeah well I mean
it could have been I fell asleep I fell
asleep at the wheel probably at least 40
times I fell asleep during driver's ed
while I was driving the car as a dry fly
the guy operate that's not the the man
the adult with the license like you're
gonna fall asleep I was like no way dude
16 seconds later [ __ ] dead asleep
right we had to pull over
there's no music right get up fall
asleep everywhere falling asleep indoors
outdoors fell asleep
oh no I've fallen asleep some really
good place did you have those friends
when you'd fall asleep they'd [ __ ] with
you I hate that [ __ ] I draw on your face
a dick no we didn't have any of that
dude all pictures dicks in your mouth or
vice versa sleep no [ __ ] here our
Vice Principal Raleigh Coleman who was
an urban gentleman who had a um a ie
black jheri curl
okay could have been black he was dark
Gerry Curran gentleman he used to sleep
in the trunk of his car at [ __ ]
recess date he got sneak over about a
teacher parking lot
just cuz didn't want to ensue yep and he
would tie off his trunk with a little
rope so it was about three inches high
and he'd get in look at that [ __ ] his
paws
Dork though you know that's not a bad
idea it'd be hot yeah Louisiana I don't
know why he liked it but I think he just
felt comfort in there somehow you know
maybe he didn't have a parent I don't
know what some of his issues jheri curl
would explain a little bit but curled up
boy Rawley ladies and gentleman very
very happy to have the man whose I think
you've done 12 movies and I would even
go so far as to say two of which that I
can think on styling head were kind of
Brown groundbreaking certainly
controversial I was I'm not gonna argue
with your map I didn't realize we'd be
doing math on this pocket yeah we're
doing that well open to I'll take those
eyes yeah go out of 12 being
groundbreaking or even memorable well
but by the way the clerk's don't don't
please let's let's take it okay I
remember when clerks came out and you
were kind of at the forefront of these
so good and the writing was so good and
all of us were like the [ __ ] is this
this crazy movie with these actors
nobody knew hopefully all the movie that
made people go oh my god I could do this
like that's the movie that kind of was
yeah launched a thousand ships and
whether those ships were seaworthy or
not it goes it's beyond the point it's
the kind of movie you see that makes you
go I want to try that
yeah I've seen something like this ball
life but I've never tried it myself punk
rock music was kind of the same way
you'd listen to music your whole life
and then all sudden you hear music
that's so primal and easy to pull that
easy to pull off but easier than
anything you'd heard before you don't
hear the Beatles and go I could do that
but you hear like god save the queen'
you go I kept I think I might be able to
pull that off the clerks was very much
that it was like the movie that made
people go oh [ __ ] is that where the bar
is so but it was also it wasn't low
because here's the difference and I
remember this so clearly the dialogue
was so [ __ ] it was crude but it was
so smart and funny and so I'm sure
everybody tried it's kind like when the
hangover came out I probably was offered
a hundred movies and and in the pitch
line was dude it's the new hangover it's
gonna be like the hangar right is it you
good luck pulling that off and one of
the things that I remember about you is
you had an interview about Dogma yeah
and I remember how smart and thoughtful
you were about it because you got you
know there are two things
chasing amy let's start with that
because that's 1997 about a gay woman
and I didn't love the gay woman yeah
written by the most rep underrepresented
gender and cinema [ __ ] 25 year old
white male yeah story I shouldn't be
telling but and now the anniversary just
passed what yesterday was the 20th
anniversary of the movie coming out and
so there have been a few think pieces of
like hey you know its 20th anniversary
but does it really hold up is it still
you know and they're like well as intent
is good and it's a very personal film
but like some of his gender politics are
dated and I'm you know I'm like look I
get it movie was made 20 years ago at
the time that's insane at the time it
was like now now it's and maybe it
smells like to this generation or
whatever like some [ __ ] mansplaining
you know let me tell you about the gauge
that's fair though I think it was first
of all let me just say this I was in at
the Beverly Hills Playhouse for 10 years
which was an acting class with Jenna
Elfman and Giovanni Ribisi and and Neil
Simon would sit in and Burt Reynolds was
come in and do scenes and Doris Roberts
was there all the time and it was just
literally you look at and go I'd be like
oh I've worked less than everybody in
this entire rewrite and chasing amy was
done as a scene know so often so often
my everything by every actor in the
world that Jeffrey Tambor and Milton
Katselas the late Milken solves both
Jeffrey Tambor of course from
transparent bandit they're like look too
much it's too much I don't want to see
the scene 1000 times so whatever you did
with that movie had such a deep impact
on the acting community at least I know
you know start a trend right it is now
it's I friend you really you don't think
so I feel like now it's the cool thing
to do I feel like I feel like there is a
time where for a minute
we had an idea that was fairly obvious
like why don't people just talk in
movies the way like they talk to their
friends like people cursed in movies and
stuff of course Eddie Murphy like cursed
more than enough to fill Beverly Hills
Cop with like fog [ __ ] [ __ ] but
just conversations about like sexual and
an adequacy or [ __ ] calm just
introducing the notion of a cop
you know what I'm saying like that now
it's crazy I was just on at midnight
last night and while they don't flat-out
say come they they make so many come
jokes
and I do feel a sense of pride in that
world you know well I didn't I'm not
necessarily I can't say like I built the
[ __ ] tower but I dug the trench a
little bit you know I'll take man like
he found my grave they were like he dug
a trench full of [ __ ] [ __ ] I can go who
[ __ ] Doug this is promised basis of
life just worry I tell you right now
firing kid that's just that just got
accumulated into our vocabulary there's
somewhere of women that don't have sex
with men but they just periodically when
it's time to have a child just drench
themselves in become trench and then
come out impregnated they don't need a
man and recive captain just saying them
we're gonna make a better world
dress yourself up got to dress yourself
up and to come come out with a kid some
of the waters of life you know
take a shot I don't know I'm just trying
to make things easier on women Brad yeah
look at a Brendan Brendan you could you
could pimp yourself out as a baby
factory right quick you'd be the calm
trench right they've dumped on the
country you'd get curiosity for the
first two episodes because people would
be like what do they talk about sports
you see yeah look why don't you I hate
to complain but why don't you guys ever
talk about come on come come on [ __ ]
obvious what did you get um did you get
a lot of like guy let's talk about here
before I get you're comfortable let's
talk about I freaked out right before
the interview yeah yeah so these guys
should know that Kevin's in my seat
because yeah there we go
Kevin goes wait a minute I don't sit
well I what he goes fat guys don't sit I
just want you to know and also I don't
like a profile of my pic I want to be
face on that sounds expressive is like
dip yourself in a cup trench okay
come Trench but I was definitely like
freaked axes like oh my god I'm sitting
normally pod I'm used to a world apart
guess there are no cameras that's why I
like podcasts right y'all are [ __ ]
thin and cut and at any given moment in
your lives there's not a bad angle for
either hold on stop let me tell you Finn
he's God is this [ __ ] couple jobs on
wood and [ __ ] like that so from here on
it all of you dudes were like bending
over like picking up something totally
naked there is no bad angle for you I
have to live in a world of constant like
there's a bad angle that's a bad angle I
don't know what side is good you know
actors actors always like this is my
good side I don't know what side of mine
is good except straight onto camera I
don't agree I think I like I like a lot
of it differently I did I he was very
nice about giving me his chair because I
was like he didn't freak out at all I
thought it's very kind of the way you
did it was definitely the way to go yeah
weird yourself
we're vote and then I felt I'm like a
city did for a moment did you both like
I can't believe we've been fortunate God
guarantee of sitting shan't turn the
video off he's right
well British man will tell you that he
has body dysmorphia I know why I know
and he literally he's always like he's
very careful at ease when he would be in
the UFC he'd be in basically his
underwear and the whole world looking at
him he was always self-conscious of he'd
be like his stomach is and you know he
tell you something I wish he was here to
talk about Ryan I worked out an episode
of the Goldbergs with Brian and it's a
lifelong journey because every time I
see him or any time I talk to Joe or
guys like you know it's brilliant that
dude who was on that episode of news
radio with you once it's like he's got a
name so it took a long time and then
finally I get to work with the momma
Goldberger some [ __ ] reason we're
chit-chatting for the first thing half
hour everyone you talked about he'd be
like so this guy's like 42 or something
like that and then the story were gone
he's like and you know I'm like 40
whatever and then he's like how old are
you everything had to do with
like numbers numbers or size it's not
what you all map what your baby got from
down there it'll be a guy from high
school and I bro this guy ran the ball
hard I'm like what how old is he 50 but
in high school I don't give a [ __ ] what
are you round the forty in high school
why can't he just be cool dude he's a
human obituary dude because like you
know no [ __ ] away they'll be like Kevin
Smith comma age 40 succumb to he just
knows everybody's about I take you in
I've always been obsessed with masculine
masculinity yeah in its on all its glory
its power yes when I see a guy come
trans thing must been very threatening
for you it's very threatened that's why
I have half a heart on a starter is one
thing and maybe you will identify was
this I started as one thing I'm a
filmmaker I direct I make this and make
that and that was how they I got to
introduce but that's it was never like I
was interested in that for like a minute
before it happened you know what I'm
saying like I fell in love with film and
then a year later I had a film stuff so
I got lucky but the moment I got into
the room or my foot in the door then I
was like I'm gonna try all these other
things so for years I've been doing
other stuff never focusing on my craft
like most people strive for excellence
in that one [ __ ] thing dominate that
one thing just focus on that and I like
early on I was like never go dominate
this [ __ ] I'm not even supposed to
[ __ ] be here today to borrow a line
from my first film like this was like a
fluke like this was me trying to see can
I make a film and we did and it got
bought luck and timing had everything to
do with it not like talent [ __ ] just
like we said the right thing at the
right time movie got bought and suddenly
I went from like working a convenience
store having a [ __ ] career and you
know suddenly I guess I could have been
like well let's strive for excellence in
the career go for Oscar gold whatever
[ __ ] but that never since that was never
the aim and that and I didn't expect to
get in that was never alike let me
strive for excellence once I got into
the room I was like that looks [ __ ]
fun we tried out that looks fun and we
tried out that looks cool like I loved
comic books so I was like I'm trying to
write for comic books my agent out here
was like what are you [ __ ] nuts
they pay $100 a page I was like how the
money dudes is you do it because like oh
my god I got a chance I do it now
so I've spun so many plates and never
really focused like myself on any one
thing like I'm kind of spread all over
and I'm certainly not spread thin and
believe me nobody would ever say that
that looks at me but when I figured out
a certain point they could get you if
you're one thing when I was a filmmaker
and just a director they could get you
and whoever they is I mean that to sound
like me you know if your film doesn't do
well you you put all your eggs in that
one basket n you then you're lying
you're part of all your eggs in that one
bit that's where I went because I'm like
after years of doing I figured it out
maybe 10 12 years in the career I was
like you know you keep defining yourself
as like filmmaker filmmaker you let him
keep defining you as filmmaker as well
that's fine because that's what I wanted
to be in the beginning and stuff but if
you're a filmmaker and your film sucks
and your failed filmmaker and if you're
a filmmaker who is not successful then
maybe you don't get to be a filmmaker
anymore and you're all [ __ ] identity
can be stripped out from under you could
you imagine and not by choice like as a
as an athlete one day you could choose
to leave yeah the support or your body
tells you get the [ __ ] out or you know
you're like I did what I wanted to do
and get out so for me I realized like a
few years back I was like well just you
know you want to be an artist in some
weird [ __ ] way self-expressed I don't
like the term art coz so alienated but
you wanted to be self expresser so just
like see if you could self Express for a
living like see if you could just be you
for a living that became my dream when I
was a kid I used to watch like match
game and [ __ ] there was a dude named
remember Charles Nelson Reilly mm-hmm
well I was like what is he [ __ ]
famous for my dad was like I don't know
but he's on everything he's not MADtv I
have no idea but he's all over the place
he was due to you was litter he was on
[ __ ] that good but what was it he did
it all the tic techno was good squares
yep [ __ ] match game like and you know
later on toward the end of his life he
was on the next episode the expose he
just did it all like Eli Wallach said
that he said do it all do everything and
I've never forgotten Kane or I talked to
our acting school he said and the Eli
Wallach wasn't the good too maddening
ugly little you're a little young to
remember him but he was
the great character actor and and he
just said I do it all he said I'll do
shut something on a ship on a cruise
ship because I like to act yeah and that
would the way I got out of his
piggybacking on that as I just said I
stopped defining myself as an actor I
started to find myself I said I'm in the
business of self-expression there you go
how tough was that though B it was very
hard your dream for a lot of people your
dream wasn't to do comedy now your dream
was to be the next Tom Hanks yeah he can
be that and still be funny as well san
george carlin the greatest of the great
backed into comedy as well like when you
hear George Carlin you're like if
there's a Mount Rushmore for comedy
Carlin's on it he didn't want that you
did not have an interest in being an
actor I want to be Danny [ __ ] Kaye he
wanted to dance and sing into movies and
be a charming [ __ ] leading man damn
and so that's what that he backed into
[ __ ] being George Carlin the comedian
and stuff and yet everyone's like if I
could [ __ ] if I could be that guy or
whatever and stuff and the redefinition
of who you think you are from what you
know you are is a important part of
every person's growth process I'm
talking like would have been important
for your mom and dad had they been given
the chance like if they didn't just have
to work and [ __ ] put food on the
table they should allow every America
should allow like a 10 or 20 year
retirement plan where it's like 10 years
in any job you get to take one month or
six months off to go [ __ ] figure out
just still want this do I still want to
be this person is there something and I
know it's like some people like [ __ ] a
[ __ ] I'm three three jobs I got time to
wonder what I want to be but that's such
an important part of it man it's like so
many people get caught in the trap of
like I got to put [ __ ] dollars on the
table food on the table and [ __ ] and
forget to dream that's how you get to be
I love how you said that I love what
that means I love redefining who you are
because once I realized that that I was
fine I was an actor and I realized that
I was more of a comic and once I let go
of that definition guess what I started
working on like crazy selling booze
yeah would you like to be silly yeah and
once I embrace that my my dramatic side
everything else kind of like came out
and I I guess I actually have never
stopped working since I kind of
conquered or
changed my definition of what I am in
the business of self-expression our
original self-expression stuff and they
identify with get a lot of athletes
struggle with it I was having this
conversation with a fighter the other
day it might been rampage and we're
talking about these older fighters
wanted to fight like a Matt Hughes you
know a guy who retired years ago and I
went I think it's because all they do is
identify with being that fighter at the
time they've never found anything else
that lights their fire there's no other
passion for them so of course they they
want to come back and fight because it's
all they know it's literally all they
know we never saw a lot of doing
anything else might be late you know
it's the ideas especially if anyone
gives you enough attention in life to be
like hey what you do and this thing is
is great you know I understand the I
understand the path some take we're like
well I'm gonna devote myself to this
sort of excellence but spin a bunch of
plates because some [ __ ] ends and if
you're trapped in it like you're stuck
with it know that there's other things
you can pivot to well there's that even
the same plate similar right like it's
not like I'm like either on podcasts or
I'm gonna do [ __ ] brain sir general e
in the same way another way to put that
also is that in the 21st century economy
there's a camera who was this famous
economist said the people that are gonna
thrive in this ever-changing in rapidly
changing world are those that can learn
unlearn learn unlearn and relearn and
you always got to be you know it's
listen minded it's yeah and also be
willing to relearn right be willing to
constantly change I've had to confront
that with social media right most people
don't want to relearn because once you
[ __ ] got something down with science
you're like ah [ __ ] done it's
comfortable but the receive the willing
to learn fantastic willing to like let
it go that's difficult because you build
experience into something or like well
all that time must have been worth
something it was for something and
sometimes it is but the moment is
[ __ ] small
you can't stretch it out forever I think
it's tough too because society whether
you're an athlete with your director if
you're an actor going to comedy once you
do something else you all come on man
we get all time stay in your lane no no
no you want that do you want me to stay
in that land I don't want to be in that
land I'm gonna go over this language
he's a nut he's a nut because he just
fought in the lane you just move you
know those lands on a bridge where
sometimes you travel and you see yeah
and all of a sudden goes from two lane
to a four lane highway for traffic all
you have to do is just like alright now
this is the [ __ ] well he's dealt what
this is a comic right so the podcast
becomes really really successful
he starts another podcast which becomes
huge so all of a sudden he's like I can
[ __ ] I don't know man something about
I'm talking and out it is and I he
secretly he wanted to perform he's
always wanted to perform and he you know
he kept talking about telling stories
and I was like I think do you want to
stand up here yeah and finally when he
admitted himself but it's funny to see
how many people you know even comics you
know until they see him and the work
he's putting in did everybody's reaction
in any time you come into a new space is
to be like come on man you know how long
you been doing comedy 20 years okay so
we were around before most cats were
doing you certainly around before I got
into doing it like I just appreciate a
comedy from the side you've seen it
change from like oh well we all know
what it is you go up there and you stand
up there and you say some [ __ ] - now
it's you can you do you could do almost
anything in a comedy club yep smoke weed
yes yeah you go up on stage and say I
want to present this I remember like
years ago me and Mosier the guide to
SModcast with and that's podcast just
turned 10 years the souls you do 10
years old this year so I'm doing four
decades yeah you know we we yeah we when
I started it was who was a Leo Laporte
had like this week in tech was mayor and
around then no nope no yeah we predate
Adam still had a radio show he did not
have a party Rogan you predate Corolla
Corolla and and and man so you the
reserve Godfather in Chris hardwood I
don't know about god I like that you
know who was Adam Curry's the first one
to the podcast who's that the old MTV
host Adam Curtis oh yeah I never listen
to it but like he was the one that kind
of invented the medium or something like
that
when I heard about I was after the Ricky
Gervais is podcast my friend Scott
Mosier was like a viewer of the Ricky
Gervais podcast
I was like what is a podcast and you
guys that's it's kind of like he goes
you know the commentary tracks we do for
the movies I said yeah he goes it's like
that but there's no movie I was like why
the [ __ ] don't we do one of these
podcasts so I got into it kind of early
on just cuz I was like nobody's stopping
us like I used to drive past radio
stations and be like man if I was rich
one day I would get myself my own radio
station my own antenna and then I could
say whatever the [ __ ] I wanted and
broadcast at any time of day get up and
broadcast and [ __ ] then all of a sudden
somebody presented this notion of like
you can have that and it's universal you
don't even need to do it for just and
you own it like you'll have a pretty
computer never - yes you want to be yeah
so wheezes so at one point Mo's was like
I need money he's like how can we make
money fast and I was like what we've
been doing SModcast for about two years
at home and we used to joke about like
imagine if we did on stage and I was
always on stage - in Q&A and [ __ ] but
Mosier couldn't get his head around like
who would want to watch two people
[ __ ] talk to each other in a comedy
club and what's his background he's a he
was a producer and now he's uh he's
still a producer now he works at
illumination the company that makes yeah
like that yeah he's working on something
big
so when when we went out like he was
weird I was doing Q&A gigs and I'd like
played Carney on stuff so I was
well-established as like a guy standing
there essentially doing stand-up but
needing the audience to ask me a
question first and then I went I was I
told my booking agent I was like I want
to go out and do a podcast like and he's
okay and came back he goes nobody
understands it and I was like what do
you mean he's like well you can't go to
a stand-up Club and sit the [ __ ] down
with your friend and talk to him no I
think it'll work it and I got like I
used to be ashamed of like I love doing
Q&A with people be like oh you're like a
comic and I'm like done that comics
don't need to ask the audience a
question comics just go up generate and
[ __ ] like that so I'd stay out of comedy
clubs because I revered comics and
comedy and stuff and never considered
myself one but and and and it like it
was kind of confirmed when I was like I
just want to go and talk to my friend
and like you don't do that sort of thing
like we did at The Improv where me and
Ralph
to babble on every [ __ ] [ __ ] how
long ago was your first show first when
we did live I guess now it's coming up
on like eight and a half nine years ago
wait are you telling us always cuz you
want royalties I'm like here's the thing
me what my big heard you guys do alright
I'm gonna need temperature I wanna taste
but we we have the great Judd Apatow
here now let's start this off do you
have an opinion on Brendan's shirt
because well it has a you know paint
like Jackson Pollock painting on it oh
you know I didn't go I wasn't painting
before this we know I'm an artist
yeah I'm an artist if you were tardy to
be a bad artist is there's just too much
paint sloppy painter but you know that's
fashion see I I don't understand
fashions about two or three years ago I
said I look weird and everything I can't
decide with my fashions I'm not like
Eurotrash guy I'm not like preppy guy so
I just someone gave me a James purse
polo shirt I said I'm just gonna wear
that and I where'd James first polo
shirt literally 95 yes I've just decided
to I'm like that's the move for like
like people aren't in the fashion that's
like jeans yeah solid he makes fun of me
awesome he bought me these boots he
bought these for me for my birthday so
give you some stuff for my 50th yeah and
I were James person in jeans I can't I
can't figure it out and so I've just
given up completely you know I remember
I you know I met Wes Anderson when he
was really young and he first moved to
town
and then at some point he just started
dressing well it just showed and you
know he was just so you know you know a
struggling filmmaker then he decided
okay this is what I look like I'm gonna
any made a choice and he looks amazing
yes like I'm like Tom Wolfe guy or
whatever and I just never could figure
out what the with the move you need a
stylist does he did he hire that's a bad
idea really I was just I was gonna say
does he have a stylist cuz I feel like
guys that hire stylist so stars go well
this is what's in right now you should
be wearing this like I don't that's not
I think he has a sense of it I have no
sense of it I never did me neither you
know also I'm always in slightly bad
shape so would clothes never look right
on me
I've always it's just found
you know it's just that I think every
shirt look wrong cuz there's nothing
worse than like a little gut you know I
call it a Fupa you there go fools God
worked cool it would bigger at least
it's a statement yeah II know it a
little bit yeah but it's it's a little
good and so there was this article about
dad bods and my friend sent it through
think you should read this article about
dad bods it just guys who have got kind
of a shitty body like slightly shitty
and I clicked on the link and there was
a photo and I swear to god the photo was
of me I was like the representation of
the dad bod when I did it Tonight Show I
finally did a stand-up on The Tonight
Show Jimmy Fallon asked me to do it but
I always thought and this was about a
year and a half ago I always thought
that he asked me because he thought it
would be amusing even if I bombed yet I
was a little more of a circus act yeah
yeah because though it isn't that I to
even asked me what my jokes were they
were just like a fireman's hit your
marks exactly nobody it was so it was a
professionally presented set but anyway
I worked really hard to do set and you
know for me as like as a kid especially
growing up in the late 70s and early 80s
The Tonight Show was a giant thing as a
comedian that really was your dream to
get on The Tonight Show and so I was on
the show and Adam Sandler was the other
guest you know my my old friend rooming
at my old roommate yeah and a few days
before it louis c.k i know a little bit
but not especially well but who was a
great guy he he wrote me an email
telling me how to do the Tonight Show oh
my god and it was long it was one of the
nicest things anyone's ever done yeah it
was just here's what you got it was just
a list of different things you wouldn't
think Wow such as this is the one that
made me laugh the most would you walk
out on stage there will be music playing
do not dance to it that music is not for
you
the advice to doug pop your head but it
also don't it's a little corny to pop
your head you're right hey I'm great I'm
just hanging out enjoying the music yeah
he also said you know one of the
scariest things ever is standing behind
the curtain while the music is playing
knowing you're about to be announced and
then suddenly you're gonna be shot out
of a rock is that because it's as scary
as as anything yeah what you should do
in that moment is you wait for your name
to be announced is just think of your
first joke only your first joke and
think about why you wrote it and think
about why it made you laugh and that
will gonna set your path for your
success and
yeah and then what was sweaty as I read
this and I thought so nice that he did
that it really blew me away and then two
hours later a second one came in with
just as long really deep it bore too
much man you ever think it was like a
magazine article and I swear to God I
took every piece of advice I seriously I
read it thought about it did it
and it was out wow cuz I one of the
things as fascinating as watching you
you know here you are the be pretty damn
successful but you're you always have
your notepad just stand up you're
writing I like the other day I came
backstage we were on the same venue and
judge writing yeah like I saw you
writing jokes and [ __ ] I was like the
guy's got his notebook out like working
[ __ ] out well I I didn't really know
another way to do it but what makes me
laugh is when I used to do stand-up so I
did it from the time I was 17 till I was
24 and I was a regular The Improv and I
got on not Letterman in The Tonight Show
but it basically everything else you'd
be young HBO young comedians special on
evening and improv and all those shows
Dennis Miller show was the show I got on
to do stand-up a lot when he had his
talk show but I don't think I wrote
anything down back then yeah I had
little notes little bullet points at all
here yeah I don't know what I was doing
I remember Larry Miller who was one of
the best comics old-time saying Jud it's
like a job and if you sit down at a desk
and you
for a few hours a day like it's a job
you'll instantly be better than
everybody yeah he said cuz nobody does
it everyone just goes to the mall it's
hard to do nobody sits and treats it
like a job and but I did it like I go
through all my old notes and there's
nothing and now I have thousands of
pages of jokes The Tonight Show why it's
because it's not as big as it used to be
right because there's so much content
out there yeah it was like you're not
like it's not it used to like back in
the day like Carson or if you're on Leno
especially Letterman at the time was
shaded Letterman in 99 and I've never
been it was part of this new committee
with me Dane Cook it was part of this
new comedian thing and I've never been I
never I don't really never suffer really
from nerves doing stand-up but I've
never been more nervous because it was
the [ __ ] stage that at well it was
where the Beatles play and where Elvis
plays I'm sure I'll think about the
Beatles laugh now but hey man couldn't
help it I know you know I know and then
I see Letterman sitting around behind a
curtain he's I saw his mug his coffee
mug made me panic
I don't know hi because it was Letterman
I was telling B this one especially when
I was riding a lot I I found like I
don't relate to a lot of comics I can
like I read the Steve Martin book it
kind of broke my heart kind of went down
a dark road or I read a bunch of other
you know comedy kind of biography stuff
like that
and but yours was one of the especially
when it's you and Adam Salem when you
first moved to LA and they just hear me
out it kind of broke my heart because
you talked about how you realized when
you saw Jim Carrey and they saw Adam
Sandler just doing prank calls that you
know you couldn't compete with those
guys kind of staged so that's when you
started riding yeah but to me that made
me sacks I'm like what here's a
brilliant mind and comedies really uh
not how you look or anything like that
and you're comparing yourself to Adam
Sandler and Jim Carrey who you're talkin
bout to freaks that's like any
basketball player but God not like
LeBron so I'm not gonna try this out
well it's a weird piece of bad luck to
be starting as a comedian at a very
young you don't want screw Jeff a well
it's funny cuz I think Adam gets annoyed
when I say this cuz he was my biggest
fan as a comedian he was always just
such a massive supporter and when I did
Carnegie Hall last year I did my set and
then
towards Adam came out into the surprise
half-hour after me than we sang song
together it was magical it really was
the best but it is like trying to be a
songwriter and your roommates John
Lennon that's what it felt like and and
then you think what am i doing I don't
think of my songs or as good as his
songs especially because what Adam was
doing was so strange and so wonderful
when he was young was really weird
singing stop it was before he wasn't
even doing the guitar he was doing you
know Elvis lives in my refrigerator very
like surreal comedy and then Jim Carrey
had just quit doing impressions and he
would go onstage and improvise the whole
Act
and half the time he would kill half the
time he would bomb but like really Bob
yeah like like people leave in masks
yeah and within the same set he'd lose
him get him back lose him and it was so
creative and I felt it at the time
watching Chandler oh this is the biggest
star in the world and no one here knows
it yeah yeah you could just feel it
bubbling up and it was very intimidating
to me because as a fan I knew I'm not
like these guys now as if someone who's
49 years old I have a lot of stories and
I have a point of view and it's and it's
different but as a kid I felt like that
screwed like I was reading I'm like that
kind of screwed I can relate to that in
the sports world because my best friend
was this guy Joe coffin Stein and he was
a 1% of the premier premier athlete he
was shredded 6 6 200 NT pounds fast me
everything I'm like well that's that's a
professional I don't know what the hell
I'm gonna do so he gave me this chip on
my shoulder where I'm like I had to work
harder because I'm not like him but when
I was reading your your book I was like
guy he got screwed kind of being best
friends Adam Sandler how him as a
roommate and that's the level that
you're more he got lucky because what he
did is went on to MIT write amazing
movies and become like this I don't
upset about the fact that I didn't do
stand-up all those years I got burnt out
on it too I love you so much I watched I
think I watched so many comedians and I
knew everyone's act inside and out I was
just was such a fan that I got a little
burnt out on it so I'd never think
myself ah man it would've been great to
be a comedian in my
30s or whatever because it's so fun now
and it's fun to do it well hey my rent
you know like there's a pressure when
you first start out to eat yeah and so
if I would go get a gig in Rancho
Cucamonga for 75 bucks
I needed that 75 bucks yes you know I
had my rent was $425 a month and I
worked for Martin wrote a self-help book
he has a new book and I radically yes a
self-help book it's it's advice from
Kevin and he is a B C he was like that I
mean I did a pilot with him in the year
2000 I as soon as you moved to LA
his manager Dave Becky said oh you got a
no Kevin loved and he was a kid we did a
pilot together it was him as you know
young wannabe actor comedian and Jason
Segel as a young wannabe actually
Poehler's young wannabe actress living
in the valley he was called North
Hollywood
and anyway Jones was in it was ABC and
then remember when Amy got that and it
didn't get picked up yeah and and and
the joke of the whole episode the whole
show was it was a young Kevin Hart who
kept talking about how giant he was
gonna be and he kept the that was his
joke
he's like he's like I'm gonna be like
Chris Tucker except you can't understand
him he talked too fast with me you can
unsay me somebody being in Chris Eyre
he's gonna say me you can't st. him and
and then a it didn't go and so we put
him on undeclared he did a bunch of
episodes of undeclared and he was in the
40 old virgin
that was what that's where and I yeah I
always thought this guy's the funniest
but I couldn't crack like I just
couldn't get the show picked up but I
couldn't get the project going and so
it's amazing to see how hard that guy
worked to make it successful tour of all
sounds still and he is a great guy and
everybody loves him in the room like he
comes in and makes the room better did
you do you know could you know something
special about him shut up because I'm
sure you see it wasn't you I can't say I
thought this guy was gonna be the
biggest community in the world what I
thought was this kind makes me laugh my
ass and he should he should be a star
please always smarty but even then he
was like friends with jay-z and he had a
sense that he had
be good at Bizness yeah even as a young
kid he used to talk about his clothes
and he would take out his clothes and he
had very thoughtfully bought all these
clothes and he would take out like a
shirt and a pair of pants and he would
call it his set he's like you like that
set like that clothes we would laugh
about it because he was acting like a
superstar as a basically unemployed
young person yeah but he you know
especially like you know like this book
was the power of intention by Wayne Dyer
the whole book is about setting goals
and how you creates a certain mental
environment to make them happen that's
all Kevin Hart did purely on instincts
there's a technique to organizing your
mind right I mean yes did to believe in
yourself and you still you feel like you
still have to do that like I this what I
just like asking these questions cuz III
oh I'm always fascinated with the fact
that success is a verb it's not a noun
well my critical voice wants me to stop
it wants you to stop oh I've got that
voice in my head that's just shut the
[ __ ] up really no one cares and I'm
always at war with a part of my brain
that is very low self-esteem it's not
all of my brain is one part of it don't
you think most horlicks have that I do I
think it drives all of us I think we're
we're constantly trying to prove that we
deserve to be up there that our work is
valuable and maybe you couldn't do the
work if you didn't have it but I am it
does not go away and as you get into
each stage of life
it it it it turns into something
slightly different but it's coming at me
I said that the other day I said you
know you're always told you have to love
yourself and it's really important to
believe in yourself and I disagree I
think that what drives me is always this
sense of inadequacy and sort of like I
have a hole I can't fill and I don't
like I've never liked myself that much
oh now I look in the mirror all the time
always looking for something to change
something bad something to kind of
improve I still believe I'm gonna be if
I keep if I really apply myself and do
more incline bench I'm 50 whereas you
are we never to climb yeah come to my
garage we'll work out I'll spot you I'll
spot you I'm gonna get that dad body or
get the dad yeah but yeah dude you have
to believe in yourself and then but
your self-hatred is what makes you funny
yeah well your characters you always
start with these like very sort of
sensitive characters like a lot of the
characters and your movies are not guys
that are benching 400 pounds or compete
they should not everybody in a bar there
in fact the exact opposite there are
these vulnerable people it's a nerds
yeah like people say and it's it's it's
due to your credit especially this day
in Hollywood they say nerds run
Hollywood
I even think like I saw Wonder Woman the
other day I even think they made a point
of making her a nerd that was part of it
that she's no all-powerful but also
weird with the guy she likes and she's
odd she doesn't fit in and the city and
I think that you know the truth is I
think everyone feels that way some
people can overcome it to a certain
extent you know that's why it's always
like funny when I forgot who I was
talking about this with but you know
when you're like with people who are
amazing like LeBron James and and
they've mastered a way to get in flow in
in their athletics just to get into the
zone where they're not doubting
themselves yeah we were talking about
Federer the other day you know this guy
just doesn't make an unforced error 34
hours and if you've ever played tennis
how hard that is yeah and and I think
for comedy you can get in that space
where you forget and you hit some gear
where you're not doubting yourself and
you're just connecting to some creative
pipe in the universe and that's where
you want to get but man it is it's a
tough place to go if you have damage
yeah you know if you have like normal
childhood psychic damage yeah to like
yourself enough to let go of your
insecurities to let your brain do it has
to do maybe that's good I don't know I
don't think I know really too many
comics that are that happy with
themselves and just uber confident yeah
I don't think like real oculus didn't
work oh it's so weird to be first bird I
just did a panel with Bill burr yeah for
Netflix it's all these like you know
comedy show runners burr it's a grunt
like 200 people couldn't kill harder oh
and the second it ends he's just like
how does people hate me
and I'm up there going I'm so unfunny
look how funny birds and he's walking
off going yet I wasn't good yeah I marry
did we did the ice house and he was like
just this time of my you know I'm
starting new stuff it's always so dicey
it's like Bill you just [ __ ] destroy
it's like like there's nothing left they
had to bring a mule instead of Ben
people and bring him out on stretchers
from laughter and energy on stage I did
a Largo with him a few months back
he's just has the most focus intense
energy is not half as intense he's never
lost his outrage it's super always has
outraged generally at the world there's
like this angry intensity about it's an
outrage I've never laughed so hard at a
comedian we're on the same bill at the
Comedy Store I get done I can't gonna
see Birdman so I win the crown who stood
in the back I was laughing so hard I
peers come in like that man
it's it's really it's remarkable because
it's also just discipline to get in a
headspace to care that much yeah that
says you could walk through it so you
make money and you're you know you have
celebrity and you're flying first-class
or whatever it is you know he's got he's
doing very well he's like our Beyonce he
can you watch be Alveston pale Beyonce
got one wasted movement like you watch I
saw in concert
it's memorise there's so much
choreography and and she's singing that
I thought how can you remember more than
four songs worth of choreography this
thousands of moves here yeah she hair
went in her mouth for a minute and she
was cool and she's like she made it into
like part of the dance yeah and it's so
focused and confident and yet that's
that's what I was thinking there's like
a flat ass I don't think of Beyonce but
I get we San sort of like her ass but
the exact dog [ __ ] you it's a flat
members of I meant he's our like our
Kendra Del Mar and I sent out the
bat-signal and the golden pony answer
yeah our boy Tony Hinchcliffe is in the
house this is an honor and a pleasure
brother the kid I know man life is good
toran doing stand-up having fun kicking
butt and then I call Rogan because I'm
like dude you know doing kind of sensual
big deal for me and actually ended up
crying on stage which is weird I got
choked up chokes up was it a time it was
a Comedy Central in 2001 like I mean
that's when it would have been like a
dream this is more people watching you
right now on this show then there are
watching all right
[Music]
I was a guest before and I just always
thought that maybe if I just went maybe
one day if one of Brian Cowens friends
get sick enough maybe it's gonna cut
from you crying to some like I've fallen
and I can't get up commercial [ __ ] was
dead Life Alert and Savior come
essentials a bummer these days it's that
big I don't know what's up with the big
tough crying I tell essentials really on
Southland they got this like this big
[ __ ] up there now crying cause he's
telling dick jokes you know what has
happened it's guys getting rear naked
choke DUP up their pain traumas up [ __ ]
man that's crying I didn't think it was
that funny by the way I would watch
every episode of the fighter and the kid
in Chinese right I cry on the comedy
cetera I finally have my chance to give
up my dreamer and I cry like a baby
anything where is the re they wouldn't
be seen in terribly I don't know why am
I so a big a masseur and I cry uh-oh
I might finally get my chance to tell a
story and all of a sudden the tear come
out of my eye I mean it's just like
there's certain things that just cut me
right to the core and like a big tough
guy like setting it's like my everything
I was hoping like damn that's really
cool man coming so it's that special
moment and I thought I'm gonna get
roasted by the roast master or you like
cool man just kind of not acknowledge
and move on nope oh my god idea though
right Chinese have someone translate I
hope they just edit everything else out
of your story out and it's just you
crying up there slow motion they're like
we need to make this that's the end
credits me so what she crying just
credits Tony hence cliff in the house
ladies and gentlemen and he's my faves
last time we were here I need more
energy i DP laughing well last time we
were here yeah I was laughing so goddamn
hey give me a second man I won't have
enough I'm just saying though it's Tony
man sorry but that's a nice earring was
took your job co-hosting and you were
laughing pretty hard you were doing the
Chinese woman we found it very fun we
made fun of me for crying uncommon yep
right on Comedy Central's I didn't try
season six point five of this is not
happening
Wilma Trevor Noah and that's what
finally broke Brendan yeah I didn't cry
on there I was close man oh I don't know
yeah I work hard all the time so that
maybe one day I could be nominated for
guests of the Julia D'Elia said he
deserves it and he he's kind of
campaigning oh yeah yeah I can't what I
can't blame him he starts the video he
bookends the video your big crystal I
didn't do the pewter you didn't do the
video it's a whole team team baby I've
seen the videos that you make Chen you
do a really good job and I think you
could have I've seen Gangnam style
before style chin how do you explain me
not being in that video after what I did
to Brendan that day what do I say here
what do I say yeah I mean you know what
it is you know cuz you're not a frequent
enough guest yeah
that's why did you you you had a one-off
I need these things I don't have chris
d'elia hair
bobby lee like baby Bobby crystal his
head he [ __ ] goes right into
obscurity
Bobby Lee normal eye balls nobody's
listening Bobby Lee gets in shape see ya
well Sasso loses
75 pounds I don't care is not likable
round head guy anymore
how am i competing with guys that I was
fans of when I was in high school on
your show Bobby Lee Will Sasso they're
in the video you think they need that
you think they need that career boost
you know what I do
you know Stan you look weird with
driving in November yet so we I mean you
guys already hit today and it's already
running
I mean Rappaport Rappaport oh yeah
that's the Gator he needs the boost have
you ever had anything in your butt no
never use as a doctor finger once and I
hate it how the doctors it's tough
oh I've had girls oh yeah girls tried I
hosted
thumbin in it when she was giving me the
old you know when there was oral yep
you've never had that Tony now I've been
lucky not what I know or unlucky yeah I
agree
could be a good time hard to keep it
together why not I know I seem like I
seem I could if I saw me and heard me
talk I'd be like that guys had a bunch
of stuff in his butt but I have a very
like virgin ass I don't want to turn you
on Brian I don't know about me there's
no story I told on Rogan I don't have
time for well you imagine how tight my
give me birth story when I had his thumb
in my ass oh I'm surprised though all
the years never had a girl one of the
tightest [ __ ] in all the comedy boom
all right you got loud farts in the
morning there you go all right this
isn't the one we'll start off with
another one we waited like a week for
Tony to be here to see this that it
happened again no it's not a real story
you made this no no another elderly
Chinese passenger tosses coins into
plane engine
yeah allegory it happened again lucky
this is photoshopped it says lucky air
stop that every lucky air it's real so
last time was on this lady takes change
it's like a good blog and throws it in
the engine and they they can't fly
you've got to be kidding yes 76 year old
woman who's letting these people near
the point we have to stop now but how do
you get near the engine like I've never
good when you so when you're walking out
on the tarmac sometimes when you're
going yeah we've done it before as
you're walking up you know the engines
right there if it's up major if it's a
major airline water doing it when birds
fly so so in airports it was a little
known fact as they have peregrine
falcons a lot of times and the reason
they have Falcons in like that they're
trained they keep the other birds away
because birds are super territorial if
you got a bunch of geese or crows flying
around some ducks and it gets in the
engine you got big problems big problem
well did well how about have you seen a
video did we do
down here did you see the video of that
those those uh those [ __ ] engines on
planes where people get sucked into him
or we did that yeah yeah oh my god it
scares me you talk about the suck it
suck with a suck zone big game for all
geez
why do Chinese women think that why do
Chinese women think that throwing coins
in a plane engines gonna be good luck
it's probably an old thing chin you have
Chan I'm asking you hey Korean I'm
Korean you are oh is that why Bobby
Lee's in the video for best I wish I
could talk about this but I can't but
yeah Chinese Buddhist thing have anyone
in your family have ever attempted to
throw change and the knot we're gonna
have the rookies right that is the most
I know I have a great idea how about we
add some rock to this Friday's roughly
enough engine dude why are a sincere I
knew he can still make fun of because
they're doing really well that's why
right now I just don't have any shame in
my game I really think that I can't
leave this even though she's 76 thinks
it's okay to throw change in a [ __ ]
airplane yeah can you imagine how hard
it must be to be an Asian pilot in the
first place right I mean out of all the
racial stereotypes let's face it
chin you've been in a car accident I
have but other people's fault you heard
I'm not gonna even these terrible
steroids no no no a we can talk about it
types exists for a reason Asian real
Asians agree and nobody knows more about
stereotypes than Asian people if you
think about it's true
well name name and ID bear with me here
but the stereotypes exist for a reason a
lot of times but name the best Asian
driver in f1 or NASCAR that's ever won
go no wait
there's none there's never been never
they end up throwing coins in their
engine and they never hit
pole position well ladies and gentlemen
it's Wednesday we have got Skylar Astin
he was frying an egg just
forty minutes ago and then he texts me
goes bro can I go to my jungle show and
I went show so bad one being shot so bad
please don't be anxious I'm bad and then
you're like well I didn't get it here
yeah get here now I have to poo I
haven't shot up you said shut it here
shut up and get here hold it get here
and we'll throw you on well throw you a
bone well throw you bomb her I feel like
maybe he's throwing us the bone he walks
in my jaw misses a [ __ ] his cool hat
that's great where when you're doing
happy in the nose if you're an artist
you were that huh yeah
hey he's an artist I want that hat and
then he's kind of like a guys it's like
he's all loose so just oh sorry guys
been shooting with Nick Nolte well I've
been shooting in Bulgaria Bulgaria guys
do Turkey and I play your play in New
York let me do it let me do a commercial
let me use your equipment to do a you
mind if I do a voiceover before we start
I try to give them some direction
because I don't know but it gives me
direction yeah that's a fair point okay
so then I gave you guys both life
direction and here we are back in a
while man it's been far too long way too
long I have a faves I've only done
I've only sang in this studio for the
big brown breakdown intro I have any
vodcasts classic hit a boredom and it's
I tune charm that's a Ginsu you skylar
astin collab and how about you song
about my very first stand-up solo ever
live that was funny I just feel like I'm
so loyal I'm such a good friend
I need a litter this is no bulls I
wouldn't do that for you I had no
definitely not and I can't sing yeah but
also just like as far as you know
getting back to me timely I always get
back you do but it's always like sorry
man can't or or no you will you'll be
like hey can you do the podcast three
minutes ago and I'm like hey man I'm in
Eastern Europe yeah very considerate hey
no no I I love you we hung out more at
box and burn we've had a lot of off air
conversations that a ton would love to
hear so I recorded it and I'm
yeah the choice behind SIA when they die
they're being recorded
what would my podcast be called behind
the velvet curtain yeah I like that card
behind you know VTS I'm gonna say
unaware I like talking to you and your
brother cuz you guys are such mm a fan
oh yeah but you out you're also in the
know so it's good to keep my ear to the
grindstone cuz you guys we've come from
a fan's perspective but you guys know
the game we've really we've really come
full circle too because we we started as
just straight-up fans you know and then
I got a little bit known for some
projects and then Dana took a liking to
me and that's how I met Chris for the
first time and now now like I'm about to
turn 30 Chris chris is gonna be at my
you know like birthday dinner he's at my
wedding I think for them when I'm when
I'm it's in New York in the West Village
you want to come yeah we're rich as [ __ ]
we will fly this their private September
23rd guys be there sorry I'm a Tempe
[ __ ] somewhere problem I'm doing
Saturday I'm doing this Canelo breakdown
it's a post-race down you moved to
Madison Wisconsin
guys it took us two years to get here
today let's just this is great that
happened did you cry when your boy Chris
Weidman won his fight I was so happy man
where was I I think I was you know where
I go the fight it was in well I didn't I
didn't it was in Long Island but I it
was like the 28th or the 22nd or
something I just wrapped graves and I
had like five days to put my [ __ ] in my
suitcase with my wife before like moving
to New York until December and I'm there
now and I'm only back for five days cuz
I'm in between things so you're going
straight from here and then going to New
York and then I'll be there till
December I'm literally here to see if
the house is still up and to like get a
bunch of winter [ __ ] and take stuff
honestly do the podcast that's why I
wanted to squeeze it in and I just got
back last night's white I'm like I'm
like you know finally got groceries it's
like the morning I make breakfast I'm
frying an egg and I'm
like well let me like see what my
Thursday is doing cuz I have all these
plans to do stuff today and you're like
get here now the only time and Here I am
perfect and I look really great I agree
I look great
no I got this hat in the village thank
you for asking no we did make sense
there's only one of them guys it's a
vintage thing come on it's not like you
could get it a lot since you've been
shooting an Albuquerque great yeah okay
now Turkey and Wales Bulgaria training
twice a day at Jacksons are they make
you clean the math how's that work yeah
just apply John with the steroids I
don't yeah hey that's it hasn't been oh
yeah it's been proof it's the hey about
that sample that be sample I'm coming in
scorching hot it's a grant I think
Phoenix huh
how does that work what is a B samples
something hit me ah so the a sample so
they always take so you piss in two jars
yes there's a and B sample so a1 they do
right away they test and the b1 they
test later right with more intricate
testing yeah but when those things get
flagged
especially the B sample it's gone
through so much stringent testing it's
not like yeah you know like I I see how
I get scram people I know who knows bro
you know he could have been he could
have been - it couldn't ain't it so we
gave him his Gatorade no no stop stop
saying what if he was on one leg dude
that might do that [ __ ] with stuff like
your dude I've taking nyquil I tested
hot now let's stop do that I see bagels
can sometimes yeah favourite like and I
get it man I wish there was an excuse I
wish there's some way we could navigate
through this but now it's just a [ __ ] up
let's let's let's hold on a second I
thought we had might have done this and
I am a pretty loyal listener I'll go
ahead but I've only listened to a couple
in the last year so here's my question
you guys should have Rapaport on again
my ears finally recovered best bro you
[ __ ] you can I just be here going in on
me already because he won best guest now
you're all you guys judge that 10 kill
him
he was great don't put I know Hey
in the year wrap in the rap give him up
on Twitter see nah I don't just let me
let me just do raps think I'm a [ __ ]
Astin yeah you [ __ ] you I know you're a
[ __ ] New York now you do theater or
some [ __ ]
but I'm the [ __ ] guest of the year
I'm friends with all these [ __ ]
rappers I'm the loudest [ __ ] person
in the world so so loud so one gear and
he's gonna go in on me you [ __ ] you
probably have no [ __ ] calluses on
your hands you [ __ ] you you [ __ ] you
know you you pretty boy [ __ ] I know I
know he'll help you Hawks me out in
basketball and I'll show you what he'll
get you in a corner and just shove you
around don't give me a favor don't toss
away here's the thing about Michael
Rapaport he was one of my favorite boy
friends of Phebe on friends and and and
I led next to Paul Rudd now because I'm
the second coming a public but um I like
him ugh Louis Pilate shots taught to me
by Glenn Holmes
true to me don't worry Jeffries who's
given the sign of him don't fight don't
fight basketball with him because I know
he throw elbows you'd have an act off no
rap would come in at you and he'd be
just big and bony and shovey and he
would just he'd all New York Street just
throw a throw he'd hit you is reach one
in Brooklyn uh doesn't matter you're you
were an artist
listen man he would he would right elbow
you a [ __ ] Broadway baby you yeah he
didn't [ __ ] come in here with you
[ __ ] oh I hit mitts I [ __ ] go left
and right and I put her on Instagram and
he fights he I get it he's a scrappy guy
yeah maybe he take me he's also 700
pounds more as a mage might love each
other though I think we would love each
other see honest with you but I have to
talk [ __ ] cuz I'm here and I'm sure it's
just [ __ ] I think the fans should
vote I think I should play come on one
more time really lobby Friday should
have the fans vote though we should do
it but you're dead you're challenging
wrapping away physically and this is my
comeback episode when we finally get
Brian out we'll do a co-host
and then I'll go a ground break down
respectful to me in my pop cake and I'll
[ __ ] comment I'll do a bunch of riffs
never will be like dude every time you
sings and I'll get more Twitter
activated a wild Michael Rapaport of
like hate tweet me something Jewish and
then I know but it'll be like you
[ __ ] Jew you're half a Jew either
good half you're you're right you're
Italian to admit pizza bagels you're not
really Jewish actually because your
mom's Italian my mom is Jewish my dad is
Jewish it's you know where's not like I
know what religion are you Italian
Jewish Muslim into your mom's Jewish
Jewish Italian was Italian
no I don't know about that bro maybe
you're lying you're not really a Jew
your dad did you my mom's my mother I
know your mother is I don't know your
dad is bro my he looks like Tony Soprano
I'm sayin Cuse here's the deal my mom's
mom is Jewish therefore it's the mother
your mother is well I'm a Jewish Asst
[ __ ] bar Mitzvahed bro man I don't know
bro you know what to be honest with you
I've always saw I've seen a lot more
Italian female rabbi at my wedding oh
wow
yeah I I crushed the cup did the whole
thing Mazel Tov did the hora had six-gun
and Chris Weidman lifting me up on my
horror I picked them out and they were
being [ __ ] because they were trying
to hit my heads into the limo John was
in there through the roof he's a bigger
fight fighter dick writer than I am
Renne with hey put me in an armbar for
Instagram yeah he don't obsessed
obsessed with their size and doesn't
watch videos on Instagram yeah you are
i watch like Brian the other day at
lunch is it's crazy man like cowboy
likes like everything I poke how many
times have you been to the ranch what
how many times you been to the ranch
cowboys my buddy
how many times he likes my view been to
the lake on the phone if you've been to
the lake okay and he gives me heavens a
wall moccasins cowboy gives me Bob he
doesn't though yes he does was less
though he gave me a one hour lesson dude
that's what cowboy does he chose he's my
kid all wrong you're throwing elbows
wrong and he shows you the little one
too with the high kick coming after all
it's his dreamy secret cheese drill way
bet don't say that he has a generic
right so cowboy you're obviously like me
more you'd like to Alma he doesn't he
likes me he likes all of my things I
just don't see them cuz I have over a
million followers very confusing with me
man you probably won't tell me what you
stuff but the difference is that I'm not
competing I'm winning whenever so
whenever some more quickly Scott
whenever a cowboy and a head so like my
videos I'm always like he Kenzo likes my
brothers and now he doesn't yeah it does
you know imma have to cut this off to
feel sick from both this talk alright
let's go offense matter it's getting the
current offense I'm pissed off right now
dropping knowledge with the coup yeah
yeah dropping knowledge dropping
knowledge with the king can you can you
sign us off with the fire in the kid are
we done we're done that's cool-looking
oh we're gonna end on that blast it's
been a long podcast my man quick triple
G Canelo you've done that already I'm
big brown breakdown so much list with 20
Jeffries and listen Glen I will I'm
halfway right now sign us off okay this
is the fighter and the kid in the best
guest of the year no well I was like
sing us off
no no you can't okay welcome I'll sing
you on you can't give yourself that yet
alright okay you want me to sing it yeah
okay do something this is the fighter
and the kid and the guy that's obviously
the best guest of the year obviously
know what I feel like yes one note
notice is that this is the probably be
sharp no because you're this is the
fight we're not a green yet that you're
that you're a great and the most
talented get down and we'll have Levi to
do something like a a doo-wop okay you
what he wants to do well oh he wants
just climb this has been a blast get
down together we could talk about [ __ ]
forever let's go to lunch maybe do some
dinner but maybe not because I should be
much thinner let's go maybe I'll come
back into
Scimitar he's gotta kill Tambor's too
soon but maybe i'll come back never this
is the fighter and the kid we're out yes
goddamn